m
[Musique]
je
m
[Musique]
oh
non
il
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
et
à
dimanche
[Musique]
non
et
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
la fête
salut à tous et bienvenue pour cette
deuxième journée de la nationscup je
suis aujourd'hui avec romain edouard
salut romain salut kevin bonjour à tous
donc romain pour cette deuxième journée
qui me rejoint au commentaire est ce que
tu as un peu regardé de loin les
résultats de la première journée
bien sûr bien sûr elle arrive alors
j'étais un peu décevant pour la pour la
team europe mais qu'a eu qu'à rencontrer
deux équipes
peut-être peut-être les deux meilleures
équipes en tout cas deux équipes très
très dangereuse donc voilà on espère un
gros come back
aujourd'hui et la chine qui nous après
qui m'a beaucoup impressionné en tout
cas armada il sacré armada junte sacré
hamada ils ont joué djoum au dernier
échiquier la championne du monde et
c'est un sacré avantage donc ils vont
être difficiles à il voit difficile à
battre mais oui oui et tu penses que
donc eux ils vont finir forcément enfin
plus ou moins forcément premier ou
deuxième et qu'ils ont déjà mis une
petite main une petite option sur une
californie n'a là je vois finir je les
vois finir très haut et ça c'est sûr en
plus en plus on connaît l'esprit chinois
dans ce genre de compétition ils sont
vraiment très très rigoureux
vraiment très soudée très travailleur
peut-être plus arty toutes les équipes
le sont mais la chine encore plus
je me rappelle de 2,3 au style me
souviens bien où il avait gagné les eaux
les olympiades dans quel championnat
les championnes olympiques les jeux
olympiques d échec chez les hommes et
chez les femmes
en même temps c'est impressionnant là et
ça c'est vraiment l'esprit chier ça
c'est vraiment l'esprit chinois en plus
du fait qu'ils sont extrêmement forts
aux échecs évidemment et donc toi aussi
tu joue en équipe de france inter que si
dans cette compétition là il ya la team
europe donc c'est c'est une zone
géographique ce n'est pas pas vraiment
par pays mais et 6,6 avait joué par
nation j'imagine que tu aurais tu aurais
été sélectionnés très probablement après
katrina presse après tu sais y alegria
les kabyè les capitaines un capitaine j
voilà qui font l'équipe qui leur
paraissent la meilleure et
oui j'espère que j'aurai été sélectionné
en tout cas tu aurais été un joueur tu
aurais été un de ceux pour ceux qui ne
te connaissent pas c'est quand même un
des meilleurs français chez pathé numéro
4 en ce moment je sais que ça change
souvent au niveau du reinking de numéro
3 ou 4 je sais pas combien exactement
ouais ça change en tout cas au niveau
européen je suis un peu plus loin ce qui
fait que effectivement je n'ai pas ma
place dans cette équipe
rock métal lorraine voilà c'était
c'était juste pour dire pour ceux qui ne
te connaissent pas vraiment et duarte un
grand maître connu en france du plus
haut niveau a été vice champion de
france je crois j'ai été champion de
france en 2012
un chien entre en 2010 ouais excuse moi
tu vois je t'ai je t'ai enlever un titre
en fait je me rappelais d'une finale
contre car à nyon avec des détours des
machins ça notre titre de vice-champion
effectivement celui là bam cette finale
dames à marquer en fait moi aussi elle
un petit peu marqué kevin est donc et a
été au dessus de 1700 lots donc de 1700
c'est un genre de barrière
on va dire mythique quand même ou fatah
ce qui se passe au dessus ceux qui ceux
qui n'y sont pas arrivés quoi ouais je
suis passé au dessus qu'une seule fois
alors je ne sais pas quel point sa
valeur mais bon c'est toujours c'est
toujours quelque chose en plus sur mon
cv voilà je peux dire que j'ai passé la
barre des 2700 you et c'est vrai qu'il
ya pas tellement de monde qui arrive
quand on suit 2007 équato aux alentours
de la 40e 50e place mondiale
40e place mondiale ouais donc c'est
quand même c'est quand même déjà un
sacré un sacré niveau mais c'est vrai
que là la team europe on a une team
incroyable avec maxime vachier lagrave
numéro 5 mondial on a les vannes aronian
on
vianne christophe bouddha guiry chez les
filles on a un hameau zitiou qui est ex
championne du monde
il nous manque entre guillemets magnus
carlsen et c'est pour dire qu'on est
dans une zone géographique aussi très
forte pour les échecs avec avec des
joueurs d'exception et en plus on n'a
même pas la russie entre guillemets qui
joue de son côté une équipe très jeune
en plus avec duda guiry lab hongrie
qu'on voit depuis longtemps mais duda
qui apportent vraiment beaucoup de sang
neuf et d'ailleurs il a apporté une
victoire importante hier un jeune
polonais qui qui gagnent des petits
cagnes qui monte au classement en fait
absolument constamment et qui maintenant
à 2774 et donc sera bientôt l'un des
candidats très très bientôt
l'un des candidats au titre mondial donc
effectivement on a une équipe on a une
équipe excellente qui pourrait gagner
c'est dommage d'avoir commencé avec
seulement 0.5 sur deux mais le tournoi
est long voilà en tout cas on va bientôt
revenir sur la fiche la première affiche
conçue bras mais ça va passer par une
victoire contre l'inde 1 en première
ronde là c'est vraiment important juste
avant de se lancer dans le match romain
si tu perds mais je voudrais juste faire
un petit rappel des règles alors pas
forcément pour les équipes invitées
puisqu'on les a on va les revoir un
petit peu toute la journée mais surtout
pour la cadence de jeu comment ça joue
donc 4 échiquier quatre joueurs qui vont
s'affronter et ils ont 25 minutes par
partie plus 10 secondes par coup donc
sont des partis qui dure à peu près une
heure à quelque chose près le grand
kevin et donc chaque équipe est
constituée de quatre titulaires on l'a
déjà vu hier trois hommes trois joueurs
mix on va dire est une femme et il ya de
remplaçant ainsi qu'un capitaine donc
tout ça ça va nous amener vers
le match du jour romain
le match de classement la gauche mais je
vais tout de suite l'enlever le match du
jour donc un d'europe 1 le premier match
du jour d'ailleurs un d'europe alors à
temps il va falloir que je louvre on
voit maxime vachier lagrave à la can si
je me trompe pas qui se met en forme en
se faisant à petit encas alors tu le
connais bien maxime
évidemment je connais je connais très
bien maxime c'est un ami depuis
maintenant au moins dix ans peut-être 15
on a le même âge on est né à un mois
d'intervalle donc il ya toujours été
au-dessus de moi au niveau échiquéen
évidemment ça a toujours été ça a
toujours été une perle des échecs
français avant qu'ils deviennent
maintenant le numéro 1 incontestable
mais voilà il a toujours été toujours
été sympathique et ça a toujours voilà
c'est un ami à moi depuis effectivement
assez longtemps et on l'a vu hier
beaucoup s'alimenter 1 pendant les
parties
il boit souvent ils mangent souvent il
fait vraiment attention à ça je sais pas
si c'est volontaire oui c'est la juste
sans arrêt fin mais en tout cas j'ai
l'impression qui fait qu'il fait
vraiment attention à de bien être
alimentés et c'est vrai qu'on l'a vu
souvent à la caméra hier boire ou manger
des petites doses je passais des fruits
secs des pommes jeu parce qu il fait 3 c
ce qui est conseillé de manger pendant
une partie d'échecs celle avantage
d'être à la maison et les toits
disposition aussi oui il a mis le
costume aujourd'hui pour pour la partie
ils entament les choses sérieuses on a
maxime très élégant qui a décidé de
gagner aujourd'hui de gagner des matches
et il va il va affronter tu vas à vie
chez adam d'action du monde connu aussi
alors on n'a pas des appariements facile
parce que maxime figure toi que en
partie rapide contre allende
il a eu avec quelques mauvaises et
quelques mauvais résultats
par contre par contre il a été très
souvent dans des positions compliquées
il a retourné parce que on connaît
certains connaissent maxime st véritable
phoenix quand ils jouent aux échecs il
est capable dans n'importe quelle
situation mauvaise de retourner voilà de
trouver des coûts qui vont tellement bt
l'adversaire jusqu'à le faire paniquer
jusqu'à retourner complètement la partie
est des fois vous gagnez donc bon on va
dire une partie où tout peut se passer
tu vois plutôt tu vois plutôt commencer
par un il va avoir les noirs donc pas
par 4 par des 4 es ce que tu le vois
jouer son répertoire dans ce tournoi est
ce que tu dois retourner un âge d'or
faux grunfeld ou est ce que il va un peu
comme roma glisse invitationnal
finalement joué un répertoire
d'ouvertures alternatifs alors
alternatifs ou est-ce que tout
simplement il a entendu ouvrir son
répertoire d'ouvertures et c'est tournoi
là sont le moment idéal pour pas
pourquoi de pratiquer un petit peu
peut-être par exemple en vue de la
seconde moitié du tourne à des candidats
donc qu'est ce que c'était vraiment des
ouvertures qu'il avait prévu
ponctuellement pour pour le magnum une
vita final je ne pense je ne pense pas
mais peut-être que peut-être que je me
trompe je pense que ça pourrait être un
nouveau répertoire qui ce qui se dessine
côté est côté français bah ça lui ferait
pas mal parce que maxime c'est quelqu'un
qui joue tout le temps tout le temps la
même chose et ça permet aux adversaires
d'être de se préparer sur seulement une
seule chose puisque maxime un répertoire
très très fixe alors c'est un avantage
c'est que il connaît tout ce qu'ils
jouent dedans l'ouverture et le connaît
très très bien mais ça facilite aussi la
préparation de l'adversaire et donc moi
ça fait longtemps que julie par exemple
que une deuxième ouverture ça serait pas
mal et donc j'étais plutôt content une
as roma gt gt des chutes sans résultat
évidemment ohmynews invitational mais
j'étais plutôt content qu'ils varient un
petit peu dans les ouvertures
c'est un conseil en tout cas que tu lui
avait donné toi en tant que pote camille
équipier en équipe de france ou autre
mais je n'étais pas le seul
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de monde qui
lui a dit et même même parfois les
réseaux sociaux s'en charger deuxième
axe qui arrête tout ça se passe toujours
mal la force
à force de jouer tout le temps des
greens feld déjà été tout le temps moi
bien jouer autre chose s'il te plaît bon
c'est évidemment après série qui est le
mieux placé pour savoir mais ça semblait
être un défaut et un manque dans son jeu
qu'il est peut être en train avec ce
confinement de de régler finalement
alors est-ce que ce qui est ce qu ils
travaillent beaucoup ou pas je ne sais
pas parce que tel et les ordinateurs
pour dresser une telle vitesse que je
pense que les joueurs se disent aussi ce
soit on va reprendre la vraie
compétition enfin la vraie compétition
là on est dans un doc c'est quand même
la line up sais pas c'est pas n'importe
quoi mais la compétition sur l'échiquier
on va peut-être la reprendre que dans
que dans six mois
quelle sera la puissance des ordinateurs
d'ici six mois
on sait que les modules d'analysé aux
échecs pour préparer les ouvertures pour
resterai très vite et donc du travail
fait maintenant peut être déjà entre
guillemets périmés d'ici six mois juste
pour revenir rapidement sur la
nationscup comme tu le disais c'est plus
une compétition d'exhibition aller alors
aller sous l'égide de la fédération
internationale des échecs
la fidh et mais c'est une compétition un
petit peu comme une laverie cup au
tennis ou une ryder cup au golf c'est
savez ça va donner un titre honorifique
c'est une compétition qui est assez
suivie mais voilà ça reste encore une
compétition très jeune c'est sa première
édition c'est
une compétition sur internet donc ça
raconte pas pour le vélo le classement
le reinking réel donc forcément les
joueurs à ce niveau là ils sont un peu
moins un plus bas à moi un piqué c'est
pas vraiment le mot mais voilà c'est pas
encore tout à fait pareil les échecs
sont en pleine mutation et les
compétitions sur internet commence à
prendre un petit peu de dégâts long mais
ça n'égale pas encore le genre et à le
romain se n'égale pas m'aimer quand même
attention alors déjà on a on a des pays
comme la comme la chine et les états
unis et la russie
évidemment qu'ils qui joue au nom de
leur propre natation et on sait que pour
ces trois pays là les titres des titres
sont très importants et je suis sûr
qu'ils accordent beaucoup d'importance à
remporter cette nation scott après les
autres équipes alors l'inde évidemment
est un petit peu être un petit peu moins
forte et après on a europe et reste du
monde
alors évidemment des joueurs sont aussi
très motivé pour défendre les couleurs
de l'europe mais c'est pas pareil quand
même que de défendre par exemple les
couleurs de la france
alors les partis ont commencé romain
alors on peut revenir rapidement sur sur
l'ouverture les joueurs qui ont débité
l'ouverture rapidement avec des quatre
des cinq donc prise du centre côté anne
hand et les noirs qui compte le centre
c4 c6 l'ouverture qu'on appelle
ouverture slave pour le contrôle du
centre je vais avancer un peu rapidement
à les joueurs qui ont développé leurs
pièces dans l'ouverture donc ça romain
c'est vraiment primordial de sortir
toutes ces pièces en début de partie
voilà et on peut commenter déjà le petit
coup de cavaler h4d blanc pour aller
chercher le fou alors le cavalier c'est
vrai a la même valeur qu'un fou trois
points chacun mais la paire de fou c'est
important aux échecs et à voir on dit
qu'avoir deux fous contrefout et
cavaliers c'est normalement un avantage
pour celui qui allait de fou donc voilà
ce qui explique ce coup cavaliers h4
donc cavalier sur le bord mais qui va
réussir hui à mettre le fou sur la cage
et si c'est donc le fouet à la merci du
cavalier donc c'est un petit peu évolué
tout ça est très théorique un romain
absolument absolument
on a eu
on a eu pas mal de parties similaires
même au dernier tournoi les candidats et
donc maxime qui continue dans son dans
son nouveau répertoire en fait pris
jouant l'ouverture cela qu'il avait il
me qui l'avait sorti aux manettes
invitationnal il ya quelques jours
donc là il ya pour les blancs quand même
deux gros avantages d'oncle avantages de
la paire de fou qui va arriver et le
contrôle du sang dont on parlait hier ce
sens de ces quatre cases qui sont très
importantes et on voit que les blancs
ont mis deux pions aux cendres qui
contrôle extrêmement bien ces cases mais
en contrepartie revanche j'ai
l'impression que les blancs se sont un
petit peu affaibli par les blancs se
sont un petit peu affaibli avec ses
coups de f3 g3 voilà on préférerait
avoir les pions un petit peu plus proche
de roi et si les noirs arrivent à un
moment donné à réagir au centre dans de
bonnes conditions avec 2,5 pouces et 5
il devrait ne pas et devra obtenir une
très bonne position mais c'est difficile
à faire
on voit bien sur la colonne c'est le
vis-à-vis avec la tour c 1 tandis que e5
ce vrai très certainement répondu par
des cinq à moi qui ai même plus on prend
1,5 à temps on va regarder un petit peu
donc 5 tu pense peut-être soit des cinq
swaptions pro 5 l'un des deux arts je me
demande si on peut va prendre le 5e
ensuite via les francos avec 4 et
prendre et prendre encore plus d espace
je sais pas ce que ça je veux juste
montrer ton idée on va pas forcément
analyse en profondeur mais cette idée
que tu as deux de créer une chaîne de
pions énorme et d'aller s'installer dans
le camp noir
exactement et en plus si le cavalier
s'en va de la case abscisse ça libère la
case des 5 pour le cavalier blanc avec
un joli tous âges puisque le plan c est
cloué à cause de repenser cette je
parlais de ce vis-à-vis tour dames
voilà c'est ça que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que
[Musique]
que les pains de faire attention à leurs
dames
alors il a joué dans b6 justement c'est
pas mal parce que tu venais de nous
illustrer ce problème et maxime qui a
mis la dame en v6 pour sortir justement
de ce vis-à-vis désagréable et peut-être
commencer à chatouiller un peu le pion
des quatre exactement surtout que s'il
est blanchi le coup de plus naturel
issifou étroit pour avoir maintenant à
vis à vis fou dames ce sont peut-être
les noirs qui pourrait prendre qui
pourrait prendre avantage de son
vis-à-vis en juin le coup eux 5 avec
l'idée sur comprend 1,5 de prendre le
chou et 3 est de gagner la partie
ah oui en plus sûre tu as créé un
paysage ouais ça j'imagine qu'un
champion du monde comme un an de le
verrai mais c'est vrai que du coup le
couffo 3 est pas si puissants qu'ils n'y
paraissent en tout cas maxime bien bien
concentré romain pour le moment à la
caméra on le voit il a il a la main
comme ça un petit peu sur sur la tête
mais c'est souvent et quand huit cantons
placent comme ça un signe de
concentration en tout cas j'ai
l'impression pour moi il est très
concentré et le fait que ce soit pas le
genre de positions auxquelles il a
habitué doit le pousser à se concentrer
davantage parce qu'il sait que voilà
quand ils jouent ces ouvertures habituel
la green fields et cetera il peut se
faire il peut se permettre d'être moins
concentré parce que son feeling général
toujours être le bon mais là ce sont des
positions un peu nouvelle pour lui donc
il faut vraiment qu'ils fassent
attention où il met ses pièces je pense
qu'un indien de jouer un bon coup ici e5
est ce qui va faire probablement en
quatre cavaliers des cinq qu'ils coûtent
plus naturel il va prendre des cinq à
mon avis c'est à dire qui va concéder au
noir de remettre de remettre un pied au
centre il va prendre la perte de change
et 6 à mon avis quand pranger 6 et il va
protéger le pion des quatre je sais pas
de quelle manière
et peut-être soit par un simple faux et
3 soi même par à-coups comme dame c3
pour essayer de s'infiltrer sur la
colonne c
ils réussirent et la colonne s'est elle
est si importante romain c'est la seule
colonne ouverte sur l'échiquier donc
c'est très important d'en prendre le
contrôle
il ya toujours cette perte de fouilles à
la structure même si c'est pas si grave
que ça un petit peu abîmés et ça
pourrait être un avantage agréable pour
le numéro un indien et un ex champion du
monde ce que j'aime pas trop dans la
position de maxime est ici aussi s'est
ouverte il mettre son roi parce que le
placement du roi aux échecs c'est très
très important
et si les blancs font peu s'il est leur
fond petit rock y aura très vite h 4 h 5
il peut être un petit peu déstabilisant
alors on va avoir un il ya des coups qui
ont été jouées dans la partie et tu vois
il est pas reparti en d5 du coup maxime
il est reparti au g8 avec le cavalier et
c'est quand même un petit aveu de
faiblesse à romain de remettre un
cavalier l'écurie a c'est parce qu'on
est
c'est parce qu'on est sans se ferment
alors peut-être qu'il a comme idée de
jouer cavalier h est suivi par kovalev 5
alors ça a été empêché par par avion dès
maintenant le pouce et 5 et d5 jouer
très rapidement des prochains
classements chaîne ans à aller voir
rendez-vous aussi compliqué jouer aussi
rapidement ça ressemble beaucoup à
maxime un petit peu moins en inde
alors est-ce qu'on pourrait être une
préparation encore du joueur indien
aussi loin dans la partie ça
m'étonnerait quand même mais pourquoi
pas où tu as les noir et blanc ont
sacrifié à un pion mais vont avoir de
belles compensation avec un cavalier qui
va s'installer en quatre par exemple
imaginons dame prend pion aux 6es à
l'air logique on pourrait simplement
échanger les dames installer un cavalier
a eu 4 ou jouer à 4 d'abord peut-être je
ne sais pas pour un petit peu m faire
faire jouer un peu ce fou de mettre la
pression sur la structure de pions ouais
et quelques petits peut-être quelques
petits soucis ici ah oui après b4
caraïbes 4 le pion cessera indéfendable
et là ça serait ça serait vraiment
gênant et on voit le carré d as she ce
qui manque un petit peu d'air à cause de
ce plan je vais 4 alors on va retourner
sur le direct écoute on est on est assez
étonné un bas c'est justement ce qui
s'est passé écoute tu as lu dans les
pensées du
du champion du monde à nantes puisque
les couples d'avion était joué quasiment
tempo à la vitesse de l'éclair aux
échecs tempo ça veut dire jouer jouer
rapidement on fout tempo salaires ont
joué du tac au tac et c'est vraiment ce
qui est en train de faire méchamment des
écoutes je suis très étonné les joueurs
ont 25 minutes pour leur parti et ils
viennent de débiter 22 coups en l'espace
de cinq six petites minutes
c'est quand même très rare toi tout
étonné et moi je suis un petit peu
dubitatif parce que j'ai l'impression
que ce que maxime a fait qu était quand
même assez douteux cavaliers g8 qu'elle
allait acheter j'y crois pas vraiment je
dois dire je pense que les blancs ont dû
rater davantage quelque part mais les
blancs jouer à tous les coups à tempo
comme tu dis est là alors on indique b4
n'était pas très bon à cause de
cavaliers aux 4 on pourrait envisager
d'autres coups comme c4 aux cavaliers c4
ou petit rock pour attaquer le plus avec
3 j'ai pas l'impression mois que
hollande est optimisé ce qui l'aurait ce
qu'il a pu leur ouverture après le début
de maxime alors je rappelle pour tous
ceux qui suivent vous voyez une petite
jauge à gauche avec le jauge blanche et
une chose noire ça c'est le la vie de
l'ordinateur sur la position alors c'est
pas l'ordinateur le plus fort du monde
qui tourne pour pour donner cette
évaluation qu'elle n'est pas forcément
juste à 100% mais elle se rapproche
quand même de la vérité en gros temps
que c'est dans les zones
que des casques juin est en rouge entre
la 5e et la quatrième ça veut dire que
c'est pas trop grave d'un joueur peut
prendre un petit avantage ou pas mais
rien de grave
en revanche si on passe en zone bleue là
ça commence à être très très grave
enfin ça peut commencer à être graves
quand on se rapproche du 3 qui s'est
côté noir ou du siceco thé blanc ça ça
peut ça peut vouloir dire un avantage
vraiment significatif donc on voit
romain que d'après l'ordinateur en tout
cas les noirs doit avoir possibilité de
trouver des des coups de défense mais
c'est pas toujours aussi simple que ça
non la position connexion est compliqué
tout simplement voilà un pion des
compensations pour le pion puisque la
solide structure noir est affaibli les
blancs la paire de fumay probablement
probablement pas plus que des
compensations
probablement un peu comme une position à
peu près égal comme l'indiquent à jojo
pour là on lui fait confiance un
généralement mai mais c'est aussi
d'autres boulots et et notre commentaire
avec romain de vous de vous aiguiller
parfois êtes-vous dit roy la jauge petit
régal mais ça peut être très difficile à
trouver la toile à vis du grand maître
romain sait que ça va ça va bien se
passer quoi côté à côté mais on a vu
c'est que les blancs n'ont pas
suffisamment de
deux pour être mieux mais que les noirs
ont suffisamment de jeu pour pouvoir
obtenir des gens un match nul alors je
te propose qu'on tente de faire comme on
l'avait fait hier c'est à dire pouvoir
vraiment car regardez cette partie on va
très vite revenir dessus juste on se
fait un petit coup de jauge sur chez les
coéquipières échiquier paris chic et
pour se faire un avis globale sur ce qui
se passe sur la team europe alors là on
a les bonnes aronian le deuxième
échiquier européen
enfin sa vie dit on est censé être être
favori est ce que tu penses que caro
nian va être capable d'avoir un gros
niveau de jeu dans ce tournoi c'est
vraiment parlé hier avec fabien il a
connu un moment tragique dans sa vie il
ya un mois de ça avec le décès de sa
compagne
est ce que tu penses que c'est quelque
chose qui va réussir à surmonter pour
pour cette compétition
je ne pense pas je l'espère je l'espère
de tout coeur
d'abord pour la team europe 1 en fait
d'abord pour lui parce que c'est
quelqu'un de très sympa et qu'ils
méritent aussi pour la team europe mais
je ne pense pas qu'il soit dans des
conditions optimales effectivement pour
jouer pour jouer une compétition à très
très haut niveau est là aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que ça serait bien qu'il
gagne avec les banques parce que c est
chic et sur lequel on est censé être le
plus favori et si on gagne pas ici il
n'est pas sûr qu'on arrive à battre
l'indre l'inde au final une victoire qui
serait primordiale pour pouvoir raccord
accroché le moins répond à raccrocher
aux premières places
on l'a vu hier il a il a joué très très
vite hier il jouait il joua à toute
blinde harry jouer tout ou tempo un tour
rapidement
ouais mais après c'est comme dirait que
fabien on espère aussi qui gagne pour le
pour le revoir reprendre le sourire et
le revoir sur sur de bons rails mais oui
ça semble quand même difficile de se
remettre si vite les échecs c'est un jeu
où le mental joue beaucoup et ça ça doit
vraiment être difficile pour lui mais on
espère on espère vraiment le voir gagner
hélas avec ça nous apporterait un gros
point la position en soi qu est ce que
tu en penses pense que je pense pas que
les noirs et de souci particulier on a
une position compliquée avec des fous
qui sont basses placer un petit peu
bizarrement le fond blanc qui en a
quatre on n'a pas l'habitude de le voir
par là bas dans ce genre de structure et
le fou noir qui est en h1 qu'on a plutôt
l'habitude de loire en russie ce donc
disposition un petit peu un petit peu
étrange mais j'ai l'impression que les
noirs voilà ici un coup comme voilà par
exemple comme à m6 pour faire de la
place aux fous au fauchage 5 ou dams et
7 pour lier les tours
si un jour les noms arrivent à chasser
le cavalier e 4 et a joué qu'à elle et
ses cinq ils sont très très bien je suis
pas particulièrement fan de ce café à
revenir dans cette partie
une menace concrète quand même ici ces
cavaliers g3 kadhafi qui attaquent le
fou si l'oeuf ou presque trois ans
serait content on gagnerait la peur de
foule en a déjà parlé
la paire de fou c'est important et
surtout g6 alors on ferait fou prend
cavaliers c6 voilà et on gagnera un pion
aux 5
donc ça c'est la menace concrète des
blancs alors peut-être que même à l'est
nord est un petit peu de jeu mais en
tout cas c'est la menace des blancs et
c'est pour ça que j'avais envie de jouer
soit f6 ou adams et 7 pour protéger au
tour des élections en amont pardon
excusez avec la menace c'est ce qu'il a
fait c'est tout moi tu protèges le pion
en amont et tuent par la menace voilà et
là on pose la question aux blancs qu'est
ce que tu veux faire parce que dans ce
genre de position leblanc
s'ils veulent davantage les blancs sont
moins bien au centre ici ils peuvent
être un jour vraiment nettement moins
bien au centre 6ème et noah arrive à
jouer f5 f5 qu' une possibilité toujours
mais il faut regarder cavaliers g5 avec
des idées comme cavalier aussi c'est c
est la seule façon d blanc et si
d'obtenir un avantage à celle d'arriver
à pousser les pions allèles dame donc du
côté gauche de l'échiquier avec à 3 des
4 c 5 mai les noirs ont passé c'est
faire par exemple sur a3 et vont tout
simplement jouer à 5 pour empêcher et b4
et je ne suis pas sûr de voir comment le
blanc vont continuer à les contourner
pas convaincu par la couverture de
l'even aronian dans cette partie c'est
tout à fait ce qu'on voit avec la jauge
un d'ailleurs c'est que ces années plus
tôt comme plutôt côté noir on voit avec
leucate a envoyé la ligne entre leucate
et 5 la frontière on voit que
l'ordinateur est tout à fait d'accord
avec ton point de vue et prouve aussi
que les noirs sont un peu mieux on va
aller voir le troisième échiquier alors
ça ça peut être notre note points forts
dans cette europe jean yanne christophe
duda dont tu parlais en introduction qui
a un énorme joueur qui est jeune et qui
est en train d'arriver au top niveau et
qui joue chez nous en troisième
échiquier mais qui nous a fait la une
ouverture qui m'a pas l'air génial je
n'aime pas trop la position des noirs
ici
alors déjà on voit la chose comme ça
pour je répète un petit peu un pour les
débutants il sort qu'ils aient leurs
repères mais mais alors pourquoi tu la
sens pas cette position
alors ici regarde les blancs alors les
noirs ont gagné un pion si je me trompe
pas mais les blancs à superbe centre des
pièces très très active une dame en âge
5 beaucoup de beaucoup plus d espace
un roi déjà à l'abri des possibilités
d'embêter les noirs avaient là avec à 4
des possibilités d'embêter les noirs
allaient le roi avec par exemple je sais
pas f4 f5
je ne sais pas trop où les noirs vont
mettre le roi dans cette partie et nos
pions de plus ne sert pas à grand chose
donc là il ya vraiment des problèmes
alors s'il n'y avait pas les dames sur
l'échiquier ce serait complètement autre
chose parce que sans les dames y aurait
pu y aurait plus l'attaqué aurait plutôt
de pression les noirs sun poserait plus
la question par exemple où dois-je
mettre mon roi et moi je me pose c'est
une question très importante puisque
comme je disais les blancs ont des
leviers des deux côtés avec à 4 f 4 est
temps que les dames chance sur
l'échiquier les noirs doivent absolument
trouver un abri pour le roi métal est
très clairement aux échecs
le but du jeu on connaît tous un c2c m
leroy échec et mat donc c'est d'enfermer
le roi adverse et donc c'est une pièce
très importante à défendre lorsque les
dames sont sur l'échiquier il ya
beaucoup de possibilités d'attaquer la
faiblesse de ce roi noir ça va être un
problème à long terme en réalité pour le
joueur polonais qui en danger et il nous
reste plus qu un échiquier pour se
refaire la cerise romain ça commence à
être un peu inquiétant on va espérer
ouvrir quelque chose d'intéressant pour
nous côté côté anna musi tchouk sur le
dernier chic et contraint piccone roues
donc partie difficile à ou la joueuse
indienne est peut-être légèrement
favorite mais j'ai l'impression que ça
se passe plutôt pas mal avec un pion des
cinq qui peut être un peu fragile et un
roi qui a un pion de moins devant lui
alors non je pense pas que le jeu
indiennes soit légèrement favori surtout
en rapide 1 à musique zouk est très très
forte et elle a été championne du monde
deux parties rapides alors je me bats
contre n'importe qui non plus évidemment
mais avec les pièces blanches
je vois plutôt un amusé tout comme comme
déjà favorite dans cette partie-là un
petit avantage
ma vie avec une structure noir un petit
peu un petit peu moins harmonieuse que
la structure blanche on va dire voilà
avec des pions qui se soutiennent pas
entre eux on voit les pions b5 c'est
cette voie là des pions une chaîne d on
ne peut pas parler d'une chaîne de pions
alors que les bons voilà trois pions
bien passé devant le roi les pions les
pions de bs et la colonne ne pour la
tour
là il reste juste améliorer un petit peu
la position des pièces alors par exemple
cavaliers enfin pour ensuite revenir en
3 ou ans ou angers 3 et il me semble que
la position blanche plus agréable non
c'est peut-être là qu'on compte est le
seul endroit où ça se passe plutôt bien
écoute on a fait un petit tour des
échiquiers je propose qu'on se
reconcentre sur la partie de du numéro
un français leader de l'équipe
européenne
on s'était quittés après le coup à 4
donc chez vichea non tu nous proposait
petit rock avec août c'est le coup qu'à
jouer maxime vachier lagrave pour
attaquer le pion f3 petit rock côté
blanc pour le défendre ses 4 qui a créé
une chaîne de deux pions justement qui
on prend des cinq pions prend b5 et les
blancs qui peuvent peut-être romain
récupérer ce plan b 5 alors qu'elle
prend b5 effectivement pareil si est le
coup naturelles et les normes vont
mettre une tour en b 8 la tour a
probablement après qu'elle va les
prendre b5 et essayer de récupérer
derrière le pion b2 alors c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé et les
blancs ont remis à leurs cavaliers en d4
pour contre attaquer sur le pion dessine
partie très tactique entre les deux
joueurs très tactique mais qui
pourraient aussi s'achever par une nulle
assez rapide parce que là on a quand
même une liquidation matériel assez
importante après tour prend b2 france et
4 que penser qu'à toutes les pièces
s'échange petit affaiblissement encore
côté noir mais cinq ans jouerai ici par
exemple je crois pas que
je crois pas que les blancs et
suffisamment de jeu pour eux pour jouer
pour le gain ici le matériel est très
réduit avec seulement avec seulement
trois pions chacun une paire de tours de
pièces et trois points chacun tous sur
la même aile petit voilà la structure la
structure blanche sera supérieur scipion
g4 est encore angers 2 mais là on voit
qui est aussi une petite faiblesse en f3
donc chacun ses faiblesses et j'irai
qu'ici ça devrait être à peu près égale
donc
maxime qui devrait pouvoir prendre un
demi point et c'est toujours une bonne
opération avec les pièces noires romain
absolument accueille ce soir face à un
ancien champion du monde au premier
échec est là nul est un résultat tout à
fait correct excellent résultat et
écoute on va on va laisser un peu la
partie se déroule à on va regarder
qu'est ce que tu penses
est-ce que tu seigneur le body language
de maxime là il reste quand même très
concentré la position semble s'approcher
du nul mais quand même ils relâchent pas
du tout sa concentration quand je pense
qu'il a un 30 calculé au maximum jusqu'à
être sûr que la position soit toi nul je
pense pas que le coutour prend b2 soit
forcée c'est le coup de plus naturel
mais c'est peut-être pas forcé donc qui
doit être en train de vérifier que de
vérifier qu'il n'y a pas de de mauvaise
blague
pas de mauvaise surprise qui peut qu'il
peut l'attendre
je pense qu'il jouera tout reprendre et
d'hommes et là il ad'autres coup
peut-être fou c'est 5 par exemple donc
vous et 5 on reprendrait pas directement
le pion des deux mais on viendrait à
chavanay un petit peu le foot est roi et
en empêcherai peut-être vous prend c4
parce que sur foot français capturés fou
prend des quatre où cavaliers pros avec
trois échecs aussi d'ailleurs comme le
montre leur dis pas jolie combinaison à
le quartier prend il y aurait un peu fou
y aurait le fou est derrière la tour qui
traîne peut-être que fout c5 et
l'obtient laquelle réfléchit maxime et
peut-être qu'il est déjà en mode tour
prend b2 fait nul est-ce que je peux
essayer de gagner argent fou ces cinq
pour tendre pour tendre un piège france
et 4 car lé point est froid et on joue
sur la fragilité du fou du foot roi
alors j'ai pas montré la varende
jusqu'au bout désole c'est que la tour
en c1 c'est encore en prison à la fin et
donc si on fait le compte
à la fin de cette variante les noirs
resterait avec une tour de plus romain
absolument est donc faussé 5-fu sonne
qui inquiète et yves blein du coup et
peiné du coup parce que ça embête show
prend ce cadre b 2
toujours attaquer en toub cavaliers des
cas ouais il peut il peut essayer d'être
gourmand et d'en vouloir plus un nid
peut il peut connaissant connaissant le
joueur j'imagine que c'est ce qu'il en
train de regarder aussi parce qu'il a
l'air concentré on a l'impression de la
tête du chasseur non un petit peu en
tout cas là il est arrivé en mode d'un
mode de calcul jusqu'à épuisement
alors il lui reste 15 minutes donc il a
vraiment le temps de calculer est-ce que
tu penses qu'ils doivent qui jette aussi
un oeil aux à ses coéquipiers
il avait poussé simple au final je fous
certains courageusement way
courageusement mais ça va être un nombre
de trouver à l'heure allemande qui
normalement à cannes le niveau pour pour
trouver les corps récit ici hein alors
il fera pas pour ans et 4 à nantes qui
perd tout de suite évidemment c'est trop
simple pour lui peut-être tu vas faire
simplement tour ces deux pour protéger
le plan b 2 quelque chose comme ça mais
maxime qui doit déjà être dans
l'anticipation de secouer chercher
comment ces deux on pourrait imaginer
tour des huit pour attaquer le cavalier
des quatre est ici les blancs or une
jolie façon de s'en sortir avec
cavaliers f5 tout simplement pour 6 des
noirs capture le kode5 de quelconque
manière il y aura foule s'en fout c'est
5 est sûr qu'il faut prendre ou 3 il y
aura cavale et prend hélas ce sont les
blancs qui retrouveront soit que
certainement un petit avantage à même un
net avantage avec le but l'option c4 qui
tombe donc tour ces deux faits parce
qu'après vu maxime
en tout cas il même sur le temps de
l'adversaire il continue à être
concentré à fond 1
ils relèvent vraiment vraiment pas sa
concentration
c'est très bien c'est très bien mais ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
personnellement m'impressionne de voir
ses joueurs les parties dures quand même
une heure c'est parce c'est pas facile
d'être concentré comme ça à 100% pendant
une heure et les joueurs du calibre de
maxime réussissent vraiment
cet exploit un peu on peut parler
d'exploit c'est quand même vraiment
difficile à faire alors là faut savoir
aussi que la team europe et coachée par
garry kasparov et garry kasparov je suis
pas sûr que ce soit le genre a bien aimé
si on va faire un petit post cacahuètes
une petite pause coca cola pendant la
partie
gary je pense que c'est bien du genre à
dire à tous ces joueurs je veux voir que
ça des parties durent une heure c'est
pas non plus le bout du monde je dois
reconcentrer pendant une heure ça met un
ipad sa part ouais il doit malgré et de
toute façon il a accès à toutes les
caméras bien évidemment pendant les
parties et ça m'étonnerait pas qu'il se
les soient mis en mode galerie et qu'ils
soient là et pied à épier chaque
mouvement de ses joueurs pour être bien
sûr de qui sort à la deuxième 1 mon avis
ça l'excité pas concentré il doit il va
pas être content mais après il a il a
laissé les bonnes un titulaire même s'il
n'a pas vraiment fait une bonne journée
hier perdu la première partie assez
facilement finalement contre artemiev
sens sans poser de grosses résistance
bon contre eux oui c'était une partie
sans histoire mais il à hilard
titulariser à nouveau alors je pense
qu'il espère lille espère lui faire
gagner une partie avec des blancs et le
relancer effectivement le choix de
l'even harmonium aronian dans l'équipe
était voilà c'est un choix risqué mais
c'est aussi
voilà ça très bien qu'il le peut le
relancer corps et de le relancer
puis qui lui voilà que et remis le pied
à l'étrier quoi il le remet à lui remis
en jeu au que deux plutôt que de marine
et voilà ce qui s'est malheureusement
passé dans sa vie c'est ces derniers
mois voilà il peut enfin se remettre
devant un échiquier et j'espère vraiment
que j'ai peur que j'ai peur que ils
soient pas en top forme mais j'espère
vraiment de tout coeur me tromper alors
écoutons peut on peut aller voir
rapidement sa partie je vais le
récupérer à la caméra si tu me donnes
une petite une petite seconde
alors je te laisse commenter la position
alors la position là que je vois pas
très joli à regarder
non mais t'es battu de statut doit
l'avoir rappelé ouais alors ouais je
pense toujours que qu'elle est blanc non
pas par les blancs on voit les bleus ont
gagné un pion quand même et blanc ont
gagné un pion mais j'ai l'impression que
nous avons beaucoup de jeu ici alors
malheureusement je peux pas faire les
petites flèches comme comme kevin mais à
quatre à être jouée à 4 vient d'être
joué derrière les noirs ont des
et la honte belle compensation ici vont
jouer ces cinq peut-être 5 à un moment
donné ils ont un pion passé protéger un
des quatre les blancs ont tous leurs
pions sur cases blanches à lachen autant
les pions la chaîne de pions h3g 2 f 3 e
4 n'est pas faible puisqu'elle est très
très solide mais par contre le pion c4
c'est une autre histoire
et si les noirs se décident de s'en
prendre aux pensées 4 en ramenant par
exemple leur fou en f 7 leur dame en a
six donc encore une fois comme kevin est
en train de gérer la technique qui va
vous offrir pour des petites flèches à
fait pour mieux vous montrer ça le pion
c4 le plancher quatre pour être en
danger
attendez j'ai juste a eu un petit un
petit imprévu
du coup ça a pris un tout petit peu plus
de temps que je que je le souhaitais
mais ça va très bientôt arriver ça peut
être un peu technique de récupérer les
caméras parce que j'avais prévu avant le
avant la retransmission une manière ça
c'est décade c'est un petit peu décalé
mais on va tout de suite tout de suite
retrouvé à le joueur arménien allez hop
la transition qui va partir par retrouve
been bien joué je veux voir mes mien
donc voilà donc pas toujours à qui a
toujours un peu un petit peu la même
posture pendant ces partis depuis pas
sûr qu'il soit vraiment très content de
sa position ici comme je le disais j'ai
l'impression que la position mais très
difficile à jouer pour les noirs ici
avec avec du c5 4 5 voire du top 6 ou f7
pour venir attaquer depuis en c4
j'aime et la dame qui arriveraient après
on va à 6 après avoir joué ses 5
c'est peut-être un petit peu l'homme
alors bizarrement les noirs ont selon le
blanc qui ont appuyé en avance mais ce
sont les noirs qui en plus de choses à
faire avec leurs pions et la c5 donc
hésiter base directement de sa faiblesse
savoir si bizarre
il ouvre la colonne pour sa tour alors
pourquoi pas il a filé qui ont quand
même hein il a redonné ce pion qui le
gênait pour essayer de jouer sur la
colonne c'est et s'activer absolument
donc l'attention des noirs ont un coût
de 1 coûts auxquels il faut faire très
attention c'est des trois échecs des
trois échecs à la découverte sur le roi
attaque la tour aux deux mais
heureusement pour les blancs et ça le
joueur arménien la vue c'est certain la
tour peut juste s'interposer enlève deux
voire même trois et les noirs ne peuvent
pas ne peuvent pas gagner de matériel
qu'ils vont faire après dan des deux
tours c'est un ils vont se réorganiser
et hawk est en prison maintenant
donc oui il faut défendre le pion mais
bon mais la position reste quand même
difficile pour les blancs j'imagine quoi
qu'il en soit puis pas la position
blanche ça c'est certain mais je jouerai
pas des trois échelles j'aurais plutôt
tendance à jouer un coup ici comme dans
bay 5 par exemple dame bessin qui a pas
de dame prend des quatre à cause de la
tour aux deux qu'ils ont fait ensuite je
jouais c5
mais peut-être que je suis resté
peut-être tour c'est un tour ces deux
tonnes de sel je me trompe
marignane qui pourrait qu'ils pourraient
se réorganiser non c'était dommage avec
les pièces blanches un romain d'être
dans une position comme comme celle là
c'est quand même plutôt le voir indien
qui pressent alors ça devient de plus en
plus difficile d'être une nouvelle idée
dans les ouvertures a effectivement
effectivement ça arrive du coup de plus
en plus souvent que des risques tourne
tourne mal une prise de risque tourne
mal pour les blancs si les noirs
connaissent bien leurs affaires et là
effectivement une bonne position pour
les normes et je pense pas que ce soit
si grave non plus à mon avis un petit
avantage pour les noirs
je pense pas car oignons va perdre cette
partie du tout
mais je ne vois pas la gagne et quand
même écoute
j'espère que tu te tue ne trompe pas en
jade juste un oeil maxime ça un petit
peu c'est un petit peu évolué côté à
côté maxime est ce que la position est
si intéressante que ça j'ai l'impression
que ça va se liquider rapidement ça va
fermer ils assez rapidement cette partie
on va voir une finale deux tours où tout
va s'échanger et même si la structure
blanche allait droit est un petit aux
meilleurs il n'y a absolument aucune
chance davantage ici pour pour les
blancs peut-être on ne m'aime pas pressé
d'aller chercher deux pions le cube et 4
donc juste une
on va fixer avec g5 pour être sûr
collections blanc n'avance pas on va
installer le rond à 6 et on va faire une
petit nul alors faire une petit nul bon
donc ça on va pas forcément même si
c'est le joueur français on va pas
forcément y revenir trop sur cette
partie rouaroua g3 qui a été jouée on
fait confiance aux deux hommes on peut
refaire le le petit tour avec jan
christoph duda une position qui semble
de plus en plus dramatique pour pour les
noirs regarde cette tour g8 qui tape qui
tape sur du dur c'est un peu triste
comme je le disais le roi blanc est
beaucoup trop bien protégées les noirs
n'avaient pas de bons endroits pour pour
l'heure où alors duda a choisi de
roquettes du grand côté mais alors les
blancs se sont pas fait prier pour
essayer d'attaquer le roi des noirs du
tout de suite à quatre des cinq les
blancs veulent ouvrir tout la position
les deux tours blanches qui sont braqués
sur le roi noir ça peut ici très mal se
passer pour les noirs et très mal et
très vite
malheureusement et donc c'est finalement
anne amouzou qui va être
celle qui va devoir tenter de mettre la
pression pour peut-être égaliser puisque
si on fait un petit résumé du match de
la situation du match on a tout à gauche
de votre écran à gauche de l'échiquier
vous avez les compositions des équipes
donc si on on s'imagine un petit peu de
ce qui pourrait arriver
maxime vachier lagrave allant du nul est
très probable les vannes aronian
contre-visite gouges iraty on imagine
que nul serait plutôt un bon résultat
même pour la team europe
jan christoph duda en grand danger au
troisième et chic et ça ferait un point
du coup pour les indiens et ce serait
donc à na la seule chance européenne
pour égaliser robin up après la priori
oui à priori je vois pas jouer mal
d'houdain s'en sortir effectivement mais
n'écartons pas quand même la possibilité
d'une victoire d'un rognant il un petit
peu moins bien mais il est quand même
beaucoup plus fort que son adversaire
beaucoup en tout cas au moins nettement
plus fort et ça reste une position
compliquée et d'un petit voilà même
s'ils ont même si on a dit qu'on aimait
bien la position d'adversaires ci a
besoin de jouer pour gagner si la cie à
rognan a besoin d'acier de cette
position pour gagner il le fera même
s'il doit prendre des risques même s'il
est un peu moins bien c'est un échiquier
où tout est encore ouvert
alors je te propose qu'on jette et qu'on
jette un oeil du coup de tête un petit
peu anasur sur la caméra à présent parce
que c'est c'est quand même sur elle que
risque de reposer nos espoirs quoi qu'il
en soit
heureusement ou malheureusement mais
mais c'est la situation de match alors
c'est pas des amis que j'ai fait le
reste le le nom de la joueuse d'hier qui
l'avait remplacé
c'est anna musi tchouk qui joue avec
avec la team europe / sur ce 4ème
échiquier et donc ça va être à elle de
l'emporter et il ya toujours ce roi un
petit peu faible côté noir et cette
structure de thion qui a toujours pas
réussi à se lier avec le pion qui n'est
pas encore arrivé en c6 et lé petit
piège parce qu'on regarde par exemple si
des noirs jouent ces cinq ici
on jouera cavalli prend b5 et sur dame
prend un cavalier il radâmes prend des
cinq échecs et là on ramasse tout on
ramasse la torah 8 au hamas et au
cavalier ou 4 et figure toi que si les
noirs jouent ces six au lieu de ces cinq
est bon le gameplay quand même avec
l'idée de bien blindé et il y aurait
quand même qui a éprouvé 5 avec d'un
grand dessein que chaque derrière ouais
donc c'est une position ça illustre bien
le danger possible lors elle a joué tous
ses 5 avec heures avec les noirs pouces
et 5 dont kader logique
maintenant ces six va devenir possible
qu'elle compte défendra le pion des 5
avec la dame
lorsqu'il se très bien avec les noir et
blanc et si cette fois repoussé
complètement toutes les pièces nord avec
par exemple f3b 4,6 est de repousser
toutes les pièces noires peut être placé
le fou en f2 pour des clous et le
cavalier des quatre cavaliers m6
peut-être le foot ne sais pas pour
acquérir le roi ouais peut-être
peut-être et b4 par exemple anne et on
vous prend pour un petit peu illustré
lorsque la dinde prend on aura quand
même une structure supérieure avec un
trou sur la case c5 une paix blessent un
f6 voilà en fait ici on a deux problèmes
des noirs principal c'est que les deux
pions les c3 et b4 bloquent complètement
les trois points adverses on a donc on a
grosso modo deux pions qui font le
travail de trois des pions c3 et b4 qui
font un travail des pions b5 ce set et
d5 est donc là la position nord
effectivement serait inférieure comment
est-ce que à anna va jouer ce qu'elle va
jouer ce coin f3 il paraît quand même
très logique hein parce que si le
cavaliere parents des six on sent qu'il
ya encore ces faiblesses à sont
peut-être encore plus visible à l'école
qui rentrent en jeu cette intention
j'avais pas vu tu vois connecté avec le
fouillent tour sur la ctn toujours très
dangereux
c'est vrai que ce coût à froid par et
paraîtrait logique du coup et on voit
anna très concentré elle était déjà très
concentré hier pendant toute sa partie
gérard c'est le point commun de tous ces
grands joueurs sont toujours un fond
c'est vrai que c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
sélectionnés dans des équipes comme ça
où il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
candidats on a tous les meilleurs les
meilleurs des meilleurs alors anna
on jette un petit coup d'oeil aux autres
matches où est-ce qu'on se concentre sur
le match de l'europe n'ont normalement
on ce qu'on semble plutôt il ya un an
c'était plutôt concentrés sur le match
de l'europe et on était revenu sur les
autres matchs après en fait d'accord
voir ce qui se passe un petit peu parce
que c'est vrai que là ça avec le money
time
et oui grille ce qui risque de se passer
beaucoup de choses dans les secondes à
venir on n'aura pas forcément le temps
de de comprendre les autres matchs et 2
et de revenir sur celui là en revanche
que ce qu'on peut regarder c'est si les
scores ont été
c'est une ouverture du score ça on peut
le voir alors ul ça reste du monde c'est
toujours 0 0 et chine russie toujours 0
0 donc personne aucune partie déterminée
apparemment et on est à 0 0 partout et
anaky a joué 3 du coup elle s'en prend
aux cavaliers 4 maintenant et elle a
trouvé le coup qui sans mettre en danger
l adversaire robin absolument donc
cavalier des six tours 700 voire entouré
risque est donc que sans doute cavaliers
m6 quand même mais les blancs ont un
petit avantage incontestable dans cette
position peut-être des quatre d'abord je
sais pas mais s'il faut revient en
recettes pour ce cas là on va jouer
déjà ici il y aura une double attaque
peut-être dames 2 qui attaquent le
toolset il attaque le plan b 5 ouais ça
gagnerait déjà un pion ça peut ça peut
aller très vite un côté très vite et
après b46 le 6 le fou revient en b si on
peut on peuple pendant les psychismes on
peut aussi faire flouer 2 par exemple
fouet f2 pour être prêt à tout moment à
reprendre deux ans des quatre du fou et
on aura ensuite un fou en des quêtes qui
serait magistral n'aura très très jolie
fou sur la case des quatre qui serait
pour ainsi dire un chat sable et qui va
mettre la pression petite hattie sur les
droits on voit que la structure noire
serait fixé là le biennois
les liens sont paralysés sont solides
mais vraiment paralysé et même même une
finale c'est à dire même une position
comme ça sans les dames les blancs
pourraient facilement avancer leurs
pions leur majorité
allez le roi donc côté droit de
l'échiquier donc avec j4h 4 etc tandis
que les la majorité des noirs la
majorité de pions allèles dames c'est à
dire les trois pions contre deux des
noirs côté gauche de l'échiquier ne
peuvent pas avancer parce qu'ils sont
pas complètement paralysée par les pions
blancs et le fou blanc donc ça ferait ça
donnerait à plus de mobilité au volant
et à la joue et qu'il réalise des six
dons qu'elle tolère avec les noirs le
coup tours 7
alors quand elle tolère tour 7 qu'est ce
qu'on a raté surtout recettes que
salaire quand même très embêtant est ce
qu il doit s que le faire ces 8 10 on va
il faut protéger le pion cced une
impression ça vraiment pas l'air génial
quand même visuellement canton une tour
arrivé comme ça surtout qui a plus y en
a sept que ça commence à attaquer les
cases proche du roi il ya un danger
énorme pour les noirs après il arrive
que ça tienne un alors pas de cavale et
aussi parce que le cava de' est cloué à
la russie ne sais pas comment on
pourrait faire avec les blancs les noirs
menace kovalev 5c sadc sally's est en
fait une énorme aux cavaliers f5
alors écoute à l'âge à la mine à tourner
la d'amendé on sait si ce pardon est pas
en 108 elle profite du coup ajustements
et aimé de clouage mais moi ça me paraît
un peu bizarre parce que d'être le roi
va bouger ou que les blanches de faux f2
la dame va t'attaquer alors que la
première nul est signée côté
maxime vachier lagrave et viennent ils
viennent de signer là nul comme prévu la
partie se diriger vers vers 7 nuls quand
on l'a quitté et s'apparente sap a raté
un roman waugh zitiou que j'ai
l'impression que c'est déjà gagné en
fait que ce qui se passe ici sur fief de
tout simplement
alors on menacerait de manger la dame à
présent parce qu'ils refusent de clouage
admettons fou prend des 4 es fou prend
des quatre y avaler afssa encore je me
suis un petit peu emballé d'accord avec
un avantage blanc quand même 1 tour 5
par exemple on va les prendre quatre
dames prend des cartons à cette fameuse
structure qu'on aime bien
la tour qui va peut-être venir en cette
même c'est un match sur g71 lorsque la
cour sera ici on na sera de faire échec
et mat angers cette menace le pion des 5
tout ça en train de bien se passer un en
train de bien se passer quand même
absolument une autre idée ici pour les
blancs se soit débité carrément kovalev
5 en juin
j'ai quatre comme l'a fait à normes tout
à l'heure alors bon c'était à carignan
ashes de maxime donc g4 avait encore
plus de sens et al qariri an d ici on
sent que seul son seul objectif c'est de
venir au f5 donc pourquoi pas j'ai
quatre du roi g2 et ceux des clous et le
cavalier des quatre comme ça en douceur
on évite kf5 qui était plus gros
problème mais peut-être tour 8
maintenant peut-être c'est pour ça que
music show que koné roux pardon à défier
médecin d'avancé si ces noms c'est 8 à
la laisse libre cours à sa tour pour
venir essayer de contester la colonne e
et échanger cette tour passive noir
contre 7 tours très active blanche
on va voir quel choix faire des visites
choc mais il ne lui reste plus que trois
minutes
alors est ce que c'est c'est suffisant
d'après toi trois minutes pour mener une
position comme ça jusqu'à la victoire
alors ça c'est pas ça que c'est bizarre
que joue aussi lentement mais peut-être
que peut-être qu'elle essaie de chercher
deux chercheurs est bien forcé aucune
position on a l'impression qu'ils
devraient avoir un gain forcé et
qu'elles ne trouvent pas et que c'est
pour ça qu'elle perd autant de temps ici
il faudrait qu'elle se mette à jouer des
coups naturel et tout irait bien dans
tout cas elle réfléchit elle passe pas
son temps
baloji autre chose que de calculer un
sas doit être calculée être calculé le
calcul là on voit là encore sur son
visage une extrême concentration d'un
petit peu de frustration en ans j'ai
l'impression scada là je pense qu'elle a
la pression du match aussi elle voit
bien que ça se passe pas très bien pour
ses ses coéquipiers juste très
rapidement quelques secondes parce que
ça a l'air d'être l'endroit décisif
vérifier que ça aille pour aronian
écoute on va faire confiance à la ch'ti
tour
ça a l'air d'aller mieux poireau nomme
du quelques péricaud de cycle et côté
est et côté duda c'est peut-être moins
pire que ça ne l'a été mais ça reste
qatar vous voyez le roi noir qui n'a
mené aucun pions autour de lui et
pendant un pion d'un pion de retard leur
wattrelos roi faible annoncé kata ça va
vraiment tout va se jouer sur sur anna
romain le sort des deux partis des deux
autres partis sa fin si dans semble être
sans semble être réglés et anna qui
rentre alors dans cette finale elle a
cherché de gains mais c'est vrai que y
avait rien à trouver malheureusement on
le sait jamais en partie dont à la
petite jauge qui nous aide comme on vous
le disait et il va lui restait que deux
minutes
romain face à 9 minutes pour koné roues
difficile d'y physique il a un avantage
c'est qu'après un échange en d4 à la
seulement deux minutes
mâcon vient d'un crémant kevin 10
secondes 10 secondes 10 secondes 10
secondes où tu en as et un à saint
clément et maintenant on a une position
quand même très très simplifié et facile
à jouer pour les blancs sans risque
voilà le problème c'est qu'elle doit
absolument gagner
alors problème et d'un autre côté au
moins tu sais ce que tu dois faire je te
dire tu as peu de temps il n'y aura pas
d'hésitation
prendre à l'aris tu peux te lâcher ça
évite d'avoir à se poser la question je
suis mieux mais j'ai pas beaucoup de
temps est ce que je risque qu est ce que
je risque pas la loi doit tout faire
pour gagner
la remontée fixé et tour 5 jouer alors
est ce qu'elles sont des adversaires
hésitent à aller aller prendre ce fou
elle veut peut-être protéger son
cavalier par un coup comme tour f8
waimes alors après tout élève de
ressources tout simplement comment on
défendre plan des cinq maintenant je
vois pas trop on fait la gueule fait la
gueule donc je pense que les changes en
d4 taux obligatoire même si la position
n'est pas très joli pour les noirs à la
une partie extrêmement importante entre
ses mains pour l'avenir de la team
europe dans cette compétition voilà
toutefois pas perdre contre l'inde à ce
serait le début de la fin a commencé par
0,5 sur trois une défaite contre contre
l'inde alors je vais pas dire contre
l'équipe l'amour la moins forte mais
l'une des équipes les moins fortes
c'est ça ça condamne rsa condamnerait à
un exploit lors du lors du match suivant
face à face à timur essaye c'est vrai
que si on perd contre l'inde et qu'on ne
réalise pas un exploit dans le match
suivant à 0.5 sur quatre je vois pas
dans quel monde la team europe pourrait
pourrait finir dans les deux premières
du groupe du groupe up la team europe
qui est pas si mal un contre la team us
puisque on est on est quand même un
petit peu meilleure au quatrième et chic
et ça sera pas battre les états unis
seraient pas non plus un exploit ce sera
un bon résultat mais ça va être un match
tendu à mon avis ce qui est le match et
de pavie pour viser les 2 pts mais deux
matches gagnés aujourd'hui pour pour la
team europe c'est avec deux matches
gagnés qu'on aurait pu vraiment revenir
revenir dans la compétition et le plus
vite possible en tout cas
alors est-ce que à rognan on a dit que
c'était à peu près égal mais est-ce que
est-ce qu'on va vraiment vers la nulle
ou est-ce que cette position ne peut
être gagnée par l'un des deux joueurs
gagner par par le joueur indien à mon
avis un malheureusement quand même un
pion bien avancé sur l'échiquier chez
pas ce que tu en penses
meehan tour ans et 7 avec de quelques
petites menaces de fous ces 3 ou dames
c'est toi j'ai l'impression que les
noirs sont qu'un les blancs sont quand
même hors danger maintenant c'est mon
impression
alors est-ce que connaissant aronian est
ce qui peut avoir envie de risquer de
tenter quelque chose on sait que c'est
un joueur alors par contre je vois pas
djebbour et je vois pas comment aronian
va pouvoir lui tenté de
de l'importer la hx1 bons coups le roi
noir va maintenant pouvoir s'abriter en
achètent sur dame c3 par exemple y aura
tous recettes je pense tout simplement
et bon j'ai du mal à voir ce que peuvent
faire les blancs pour essayer de gagner
parce que par exemple imaginons l
échange de tours ici dams et quatre
échecs pour voir h7 est pour ça qu on
appelait h6 dame prend pion à quatre ça
se fait très risquée d'un noir qui
débarqueraient par exemple en e2
ouais ça fait peur à quatre derrière ça
fait pas envie côté blanc alors après tu
peux revenir et que la dame en f4 et
venir tout et les ventes est d'accord
bon même là il y aurait pas vraiment de
chance de gain mais après à la vue du
match ça peut donner envie à aller vonn
de tenter d'en unaf et dames ces cinq
écoutes
ils empêchent les changes détour avec
tours 7
oui manade pouces et 3 donc se séparent
c'est pas mal ce qu'il a fait un fouet
joué à vii pour faire tous des cinq tous
les cinq qu'il ya une sacrée menaces
probablement deux solutions soit tu mets
quelque chose en c3 pour être attaqué
sur g7 alors tous ces trois pour
empêcher le foot c'est de bouger à cause
de tout reproche de cet échec
effectivement poussé trois peut-être
tour des huit par exemple peut aussi
pousser des deux ça fait un peu peur
c'est quand même les noirs qui
continuent à mettre un peu de pression
ici rappelé que la position à un peu
plus sympa à jouer pour les normes et à
côté tout ça est ce qu'on peut voir un
miracle écoute il est toujours en vie ce
qui est assez tout bonnement lieu quand
un deuxième pion ces quatre mois je
pense que notre ami gary né ce ne sera
pas très content de cette partie
peut-être se faire virer non mais ça va
vraiment où se jouer sur sur à narnia
écoute regarde picchi piccone rookie qui
dépense du temps la roma c'est elle qui
est finalement à la position
difficile et parfois dans ces matches ça
peut être un peu bizarre mais c'est il
arrive que ce soit le joueur qui doivent
faire là nul qui est plus de pression
psychologique que celui qui doit gagner
ces espèces de pression défensive quoi
en fait des morts sont vraiment en
grande difficulté parce qu'après un
échange en d4 ne pense pas que tour des
huit soit une bonne option puisque red
tour sete qui menace de plonger sept
matches il forcerait par exemple quelque
chose comme d'ahmed 6 et le pion c7
serait perdue donc jouer une finale un
petit peu de cet acabit mais c'est
peut-être la meilleure chance 1 pour les
noirs et ses 14 je me demandais si on
était obligé même de d'échanger 1 ap 6
effectivement on ne veut pas liquide et
où ses pions à l'alba donc peut-être
simplement tour pense que cet échange
est comme ceux ci s est remis à près de
c'est un gros gros puis en avance pour
les blancs ouais ça ça devrait être une
victoire blanche cette position et six
tours lui était pas possible alors que
ce qu'on fait par un échec
tu es 3 2 pour prendre b2 sur échec
mystère très très risqué aussi un le
truc c'est que t'as plus trop de gars en
défense après 1
mais bon c'est peut-être lui la
meilleure chance pratique on va rester
on va rester sur la position du direct
parce qu'il reste plus qu'une minute 50
romain et on devrait rapidement voir un
coup maintenant côté côté noir une 45
jusqu'à que jusqu à quel moment tu te
mets ma l'otan tu tu dois jouer un coup
là non côté noir tu peut plus laisser le
chronomètre filet comme ça il faut life
aux jo il faut jean un coup
effectivement décision moi je pense que
ça va faire deux partout ce match parce
qu'elle va gagner musique zouk tout cas
là alors je vais dire que la russie
avait ouvert le score contre la chine
avec une victoire bart et miev contre
wade dit gros chine a aussi on reviendra
dessus après ouais la russie qui
pourrait à
pourrait gagner le match est
complètement relancé tout le monde ainsi
la russie gagne sinon à leur première
défaite et ça relancerait toutes les
autres équipes à la poursuite alors
c'est plutôt parti pour faire 2 partout
c'était plutôt parti pour faire de
partout mais on reviendra dessus après
alors le tour 5 qui a été joué donc koné
ou qui n'a plus que 50 secondes roma
elle se met vraiment très très mal
autant la joueuse indienne écoute on a
là on l'a appelé à réfléchir parce qu'on
a des anges on a dit que ce notre seul
problème sur cet échiquier c'était le
temps et coûte là nous a gâtés un pic
bonnet rouge sang de sept minutes à la à
30 secondes
elle n'a pu l naples en deux temps 1 et
10 secondes d'un crémant parcours s'est
pas beaucoup finalement alors à la joue
et dan décède après une longue réflexion
elle protège son cavalier et elle vient
quelque part couvrir aussi le pion g7
alors pêche la tour devenir 7 6 le
cavalier de voeux
si le cavalier venait à disparaître
kasab 5 alors est-ce qu'un coucou c5 est
envisageable pour mettre la pression le
rate on va voir elle a joué est là je
faisais 5 justement à n'a plus que 30
secondes côté côté indien naturel et là
on peut à un moment donné ça va passer
par g4 mais alors est-ce qu'on peut
préparer ça tranquillement avec un coup
comme dame eu un doublé doublé sur la
colonne e empêcher tour vite parce que
si les normes ont un coup à jouer au
prochain coup ses tours 8
pour liquider la dernière tour et là ça
serait déjà beaucoup mieux pour les
noirs la russie j'ai envie de jouer
d'amr ou alors peut-être dame eux deux
mais je voulais éviter de laisser cet
échec traîner un sur la première rangée
et peut-être que si rien au monde
rec 2 donc d'amener la route à me2
mesdames heures à l'air d'être le coup
le plus humain et si oui tu contrôles
aussi un petit peu l'écart il ya quatre
ans quand il a jugé qu as tu auras pas
de calais h4 et qui met en ondes à main
moi ça ne paraît vraiment un naturel ici
wes apparaître un cours
coût très naturel pour les blancs il
reste plus qu'une minute anna s'ils
jouent g4 directe et qu'il laisse qu'un
valet h4 elle laisse cavaliers h4 alors
écoute à la bien dû calculer car alliage
4 et ours est un c c'est la variante
qu'elle a du calcul elle a pris 54
secondes pour jeu le coup donc elle a dû
peser le bleu contre salaire 12 hockey -
cavaler h quatre tours sète la dame où
va la dame noire noire qui va peut-être
repartiront dès 8 ans et 8 à la pas trop
le choix les la fois fois accéléré à la
folle envoyé le tour sept c'est ce qu'a
l'a calculé ça sert à rien de laisser
respirer l'adversaire et à la fordham au
dos au cou lapointe attention à des
dames 6 selon ou à la dame noire à des
dames e5 way dames 200 m dos dames 5 un
pic onéreux on commence à voir les
dixièmes de seconde
la dame qui repart en est vite il faut
des quatre donc d'un des huit seul
couple dame de évidemment on regardait
les trois protégés en menace dames 6 on
menace pas d'anneau 5 comme je le disais
parce qu'à kiev 3 en revanche on menace
est soudé 4 alors elle a joué cavalier
g6 elle vient attaquer la tour et
peut-être se replacer vers f 4l c'est
peut-être elle c'est elle pressé avec le
pouget 4-1 avez le temps s'est pressé à
mon avis damien c'était toi avec 30
secondes à l'adversaire dames 1 à mon
avis c'était la victoire presque sûr et
là effectivement ça se complique
est-ce qui perdit vente et dames 6 tours
pranger c'est des fous qui reviennent en
d4
vas y aurait un mort un père pète un
échec perpétuelle certainement derrière
mais pas plus c'est ça le problème
maintenant c'est que elle est partie
dans une variante tactique et soit ça
marche soit ça marche pas là il ya plus
de il ya plus de bluff c'est le genre de
coups qu'il faut éviter quand on est
content quand on est en direct notre
camp mais surtout surtout quand les deux
sont des t-notes parce que parce que
c'est une décision concrète jeudi en
fait c'est pas un coup évité s'il ya une
alternative forte est simple mais là ce
café
musique succès à l'air pas mal sur le
tour reste un rêve cette empêche les f4
menaces ou des 4 et maintenant il peut
peut-être échanger faire revivre le fou
sur des attraits et cadets si on force
tour g8 la finale va être complètement
gagnante
ouais il sent le 30 secondes pour les
deux joueuses s'est échangé à 8 ça va
reprendre le fou qui va revenir en d4 la
tourangelle 8 et et après le cavalier a
plus trop de garoua f2 en premier c'est
étonnant ça m'inquiète et aux cinq
attaques latour menace qu'est détroit et
des noirs gagne oui exactement
elle m'a été demandé de faire tout à
fait incroyable alors que fout des
quatre gagné la partie autour se sait
tous que ouais ça a été joué cavalier e
ça a joué on regarde sur son visage on
voit on voit la déception sur son visage
regarde ça se voit ça se voit clairement
incroyable elle avait tellement bien de
travailler dans cette partie mais tu es
fou en d4 est bloqué car l ie 5 et on va
on va remontrer quand même un pour être
bien sûr que vous ayez bien le truc en
tête fou des cats qui menaçait fou prend
g7 n'y avait pas camaïeu 5 passes qui
auraient eu fou prend tout reprend et
tous réfutent mat
donc ça aurait gagné et sa force et
comme le disent et romain la tour à me
ranger 8 et il y avait en le 7 mai où
pranger c'est en tout cas c'était c'est
un gars limpide simplicité noirs sont
paralysés un peu jouer ce qu'on veut f4v
quatre points f2 maintenant ce serait le
bon moment
est-ce que l'a voulu est ce qu'elle a
voulu jouer food et 4 suivi par marc
webb 2 et la 3 f 2 en premier c'est des
choses qui arrivent aux échecs des fois
de tromper deux d'or deux coups alors
elle va tout tenter un de toute façon
maintenant elle doit elle doit jouer
leur va-tout on fait juste un tout petit
tour exprès pour voir duda écoute toute
assez peut-être plus si perdant que ça
c'est je sais pas comment il a fait ça
mais mais peut-être que yann christophe
sauvé sourire on ne l'a sauvée et je
crois qu'il ya une très très bonne
surprise chez notre ami à rognan qui je
cois gagne incroyable incroyable romain
pendant que vous regardez de l'autre
côté
vous l'avez pas vu on l'a on n'a pas pu
mettre la cam mais maxime vachier
lagrave qui était très heureux à la
caméra de son côté alors les bonnes
aronian on va le mettre à la cam à la
mène
on a une position très très esthétique
que kevin avec les nord qui sont
paralysés le fou qui est paralysé en c2
par ses propres pions la dame noire qui
est paralysé à la défense du plan d'eau
c'est telenor qui vont faire à 5 à 6 a
pris car pour les blancs par les noirs
c'est complètement perdu il a l'air
heureux
les vols il a l'air heureux c'est cool
ça fait plaisir il va il va mettre une
belle victoire
les noirs dont plus de coups
complètement fermé la team europe alors
compensé après la gaffe dana que c'était
fini et finalement tu vois il s'est
passé des choses sur les autres
échiquiers lui qui va peu la tumeur qui
va peut-être gagner et maintenant parce
que là je pense pas qu'elle soit quand
même moins bien
ne crions pas victoire trop vite dans ma
bulle
on n'en faut calculer roi prend des 1 on
apprend des 1
mais qu'est ce qu'il veut faire on va
voir
il a pu reprendre un des deux alors il
me lâche près maasdam c2a effet d'un
projet cette prise j'ai cette prise g7
il va prendre des deux c'est bien joué
de la part de l'even et qui ont acquis
instoppable even qui met le poing
victoire ouais voilà le petit sourire
qui fait plaisir aux mains alors là
alors comment il sait comment est-ce
qu'il arrive à ça c'est un magicien
aronson bien réussi à s'il était fou
noir qui arrivait en c2 et david a fait
un coup de magiciens sans doute un
moment un coup de b4 quelque part aissi
coup de magicien b 4-1 apprend dès 4 ans
passant sous les 2 et les noirs sont
paralysés heureux c'est magnifique
ouais ça ça pourrait bien finir dans un
bouquin c'est un prix de beauté cette
position pour jan christoph elle est
facile il ya pas de problème donc on va
regarder
évitez de la permanence à va faire nul
donc du coup la timone qui va gagner
mais pas là où on le pensait oui match
nul signé entre les deux joueuses
et il reste plus que que jan christoph
et il devrait y devrait y arriver
tranquillement à faire affaire sept nuls
romain ça ça pose aucun problème pour un
joueur professionnel j'imagine
absolument aucun je ne pense pas que ça
va jouer très longtemps écouté un match
avec un scénario complètement inattendu
en vous disais dans ces deux autres
partis normalement duda qui va perdre et
heleven qui va faire nul est finalement
on doit regarder comment d'audard réussi
ce miracle ouais ça alors on va revenir
plus ou moins où on en est et vêtements
tout eu deux points de moins mais il a
trouvé du contre je on est passé un peu
vite localité en fait quand même trois
pions mais blanc devrait elam c6 et là
c'est à jouer f4 lieu de alors attends
je vais revenir à mince alors et s'il
avait joué s4 obtenir le pion tout
simplement écoute il aurait pu un jour
est plutôt un roi des singes en rallye
plutôt tour 3 d'abord avant rodez 5 mais
peut-être que j'ai mis à vendre de
l'ordinateur d'accord il va dès 5h 4 aïe
ça a évidemment évidemment et le roi
retourne avec cette position nul
théorique où les blancs ont un pion et
un food avance 7 les champs sera
gagnante si les noirs avaient refoulé
blandin foot cases noires mais avec un
fou de cases blanches et un pion h ça ne
passe pas et noir attendent dans le coin
et sa fille qui a pas fait f4 parce
qu'effectivement ça rendait la tâche des
noirs trop facile et du coup mouture 3
était inutile c'est pour çà roi des cinq
et on reprend 2,5
ça allait très bien et l'annuler signé
ea c'est gagné côté européen un match en
match et un hold up en c1 auld a promis
alors hold up j'irai pas j'irai pas
jusque là mais
on était quand même gagnants que j'ai
quand même gagné au quatrième et chic et
mais c'est vrai que on va dire que un an
et demi sur deux au deuxième et
troisième échiquier est un hold up un
petit peu ouais donc belle victoire de
l'équipe européenne qui se relance
complètement dans la compétition je met
le score des autres matches pour voir
que la team us mn je mets juste et
serein pour le moment et voilà donc
chine russie
ces matches nuls donc on va aller voir
la dernière partie qui oppose dominguez
ahfir hodja donc pour une éventuelle
égalisation de la team reste du monde
mais faudrait-il encore pour ça que
firent ouja réussissent à battre
dominguez joueur d'origine cubaine enfin
joueurs cubain de naissance et qui joue
maintenant pour les états unis et romain
effectivement il me semble que nous
sommes pas que les blancs et la vente
pagis y voit la petite jauge à gauche un
qui semble plutôt favorisé les noirs
comme un lieu de l'échec attention à des
petits réseaux de maths dominguez qui a
été champion du monde de blitz
il ya quelques années attention à 20
secondes le pion jeu qui file
mais il va falloir être très concret
alors cavaliers f2 et cheikh rage de
bien jolies images de ce qu'ils n'y a
pas d'échec perpétuel un montant ht avec
l'euro a évidemment un échec perpétuelle
ça c'est un échec
quand on ne peut pas éviter des échecs
qui se répète ce qui ferait nul et
ayissi match nul pour la team ou
essayent serait synonyme de victoire
donc 2010 qu'est-ce qui peut chercher
qui menacent matin d'un coup donc on
parlait bien de réseaux de maths donc il
y avait un réseau de matin et tours j'ai
deux donne à tout projet de rapprocher
d'eux et ensuite tu es blanc vont tout
miser sur leur plongée ils jouent fou
prend gdf et paquets relief carte qui a
floué de jeu c'est pas bon ça joue vite
ils ont plus beaucoup de temps alors à
ton attention avec quelques
eq aussi petain attendu à le foot le
cavalier de cette emprise mais avec tout
projet 5
il n'y a pas assez d'eux est passé de
matériel ici pour elle pour les blancs
pour espérer quelque chose
il va quand même l'attenté j'imagine
alors je peux l'attenté mais je pense
qu'ici le plus simple pour les noirs ça
serait de remettre une tour ans est le
roi c'est 7 par exemple je vois pas trop
le pion à 5 à tout moment à tout moment
les noirs peuvent jouer v5 évidemment
pour liquider le dernier pion mais je
pense pas que les blancs et de puisse
obtenir ici tout fou contre tours qui
l'honneur ils sont mais c'est à dire que
même si on arrivait à échanger le pion à
4 contre les quatre pions noirs la
position serait encore nulle en intérim
et mais là il y aura une défense
importantes à faire côté noir si rouge
alerte il vient de proposer nul alors je
ne sais pas pourquoi 2010 n'accepte pas
et c'est ça accepté et ça veut dire que
c'est une victoire pour la team usa qui
va le reste du monde et donc c'est quoi
les résultats alors aujourd'hui là pour
cette première on donc on a dix matches
nuls entre la chine et la russie deux
partout la team europe qui bat l'inde
deux ennemis à et demi est hélas timur
essai qui bat le reste du monde de miens
et demi je sais pas si le classement est
mis à jour déjà j'ai bien l'impression
est donc ça veut dire chine etats unis
devant avec 5 points europe 3e avec
trois points reste du monde et russie 2
points et l'inde n'a qu'un point qui
ferme jacky faire la large ça semble
difficile pour les indiens déjà romain
70 puis s'il s'annonçait difficile
attention ils ont ils ont que des
joueurs dangereux donc ils peuvent
battre n'importe quelle équipe mais
évidemment comparé à la russie à la
chine notamment il y en a un sacré écart
et il y avait aussi un bel écart avec la
team europe même si même si ça c'est pas
tant vu que ça dans ce match on a un peu
suez complètement suez
on a complètement sûr mais on a gagné
c'est plus important je n'ai alors
peut-être un petit tour d un petit tour
des victoires par exemple
ding yifan libanais pomme nachi ou
encore artemiev kibawa guy abord fait
les parties décisives des autres matches
et que tu suis tout à fait d'accord avec
toi
il va falloir que je trouve la partie
alors on peut regarder cette partie donc
qui a opposé oui avec les blancs à
nepomniachi donc c'était une grünfeld
couverture fétiche du joueur russe
d'affilée un petit peu les coûts ici
c'est des choses qu'on a des choses qui
sont connus des variantes connues
non c'est une position tout à fait
théorique france et 5 par contre la
seconde vie depuis ont donné pomme nachi
je n'avais jamais vu qu'est ce qui va et
ce qu'il agace qu'il a gaffé depuis on
se sent que c'est un médecin m'a quand
même mais partie simple enchaîné comme
ça et c'est vrai que là les blancs sont
déjà très bien il n'y a plus le fou du
fian kg et aux actions qu'il a gaffé
très vite nepomniachi cette partie est
ce que skb 5 il a raté vous prend vous
pensez ça tout simplement parce que je
sois pas trop pour bien montrer un
l'option était protégé jusque là par la
dame
il y aurait peut-être café b5 pour faire
une expansion allèles dames le la dalle
ne protège plus et tout d'un coup ghimpu
français 5 alors à une gaffe
hallucinante si on a vu la caméra si on
n'est pas menée à dechy à ce moment là
on aurait pu en avoir la certitude parce
qu'il a certainement dû faire la grimace
sauf s'ils s'étaient préparés évidemment
la flexion tour ses huit ça fout des
caries s'y retrouver vraiment très mal
tout de suite un safari
c'est ce que je remarque que sur foot
pro f3 et blanc n'ont pas fait depuis on
prend trois est ce que est ce que n'est
pas venu à jean s'est pas trompé un jour
un tour c'est 8 qui n'aurait pas plus
peur pour un f3 en premier comme ça il y
aurait eu fusion prend tu veux dire
force est bien points et ensuite faire
tourner ses huit sur fouet 4 a priori et
noir auraient beaucoup de jeu mais c'est
pas la même
ce qu on échange on va reprendre le même
d'un point à 2 par exemple ou cavaliers
17 nice y aurait donc eu des
compensations effectivement sur le pion
de ces trois il ya moins le problème des
casses noir donc peut-être fou b4 est
pas fou des 4 j'ai l'impression que
c'était peut-être une prépa nepomniachi
et qui nient la lys trompeur j'entends
ces huit tout simplement aurait pu
inverser les coûts et après est vraiment
très malade faute en gohelle sans le
foot case mal rangée 7
en général c'est penguin feuille de
temps mais là ça va beaucoup mieux
ouais on est passé un peu vite su penser
en fait que ça allait être un oiseau
fakhri alors que ce qui s'est passé
on va revenir 30 jusque là ça semble
tellement écrasant vous pouvez même voir
la jauge inquiets qui est très à
l'avantagé des plans qui ont
effectivement une tour qui a eu ragon
mes deux genoux g6 finalement 1 est
aussi fort que le fou j'ai c'est de la
graine fait bizarre un difficile de dire
à quel moment précis ça a tourné il ya
un petit peu de 1,10 peu de jeu comme
comme souvent dans la bonne file
d'ailleurs très difficile de dire à quel
moment ça a tourné mais finalement mais
ça reste un saut c'est encore un pion de
plus pour les blancs nepomniachi qui a
perdu la partie de foi du oui à des six
jolies passes un peu vite un pour se
faire une idée comme on est des joueurs
ont gagné ou perdu le set qui l'en la
tour en 8,6 comme ça et en cas de prises
en huit ans va reprendre des pions avec
promotion dames et on va gagner
pièces facilement gagnante
ça c'était le gain côté à côté russe
maintenant on va essayer de chercher à
ça à gagner qu'on veut côté chinois
pardon c'est qui qui a gagné pour pour
les russes
certaines heures alors artemiev artemiev
qui vous bien dernièrement depuis le
confinement c'est là il avait gagné le
tournoi l'abu dhabi masters organisés
partie à ce point comme une des neuf qui
n'a pas l'air d'être d'un hors jeu plus
que ça parce confinement il envoie
vraiment du lourd et jouer contre eux
oui c'était une anglaise ça paraissait
suppositions tout à fait normal la
sortie couverture ça paraissait ça
paraît très symétriques mai mais blanc
et un meilleur développement fois çi ce
cap il attend de reprendre le plan ce 5
mai finit par le reprendre oui les noirs
sont paralysés le fou c'est 8 qui est
pas qui est très passif pour la
repousser 8 par rapport au choix chis
les deux fous blanc il joue sur quelque
chose est fou c'est 8 il est
complètement bloquée dans des pièces
blanches sont vraiment optimales alors
comment il a concrétisé sa civic
moi j'ai cette fois empêché fou est six
à harak ti pierre petit petites
tactiques car déjà que les positions
étaient pas bonnes tout prend injustice
qui ramassent du matériel alors la
partie catastrophique de wailly
car si catastrophique mais belles
parties de dart nf qui a gagné dans son
style un parti modèle d'un seigneur
effectivement il est quand même assez
impressionnant dans ses petites parties
stratégiques la wii
la déposition l'air de rien tu as
l'impression que qui a rien et puis
finalement en l'espace de trois quatre
cinq coups il réussit à mettre une
pression d'enfer
c'est vraiment un orfèvre pour faire ça
je sais pas où sont exactement de
tromper les noirs parce qu'ici s'avère
assez proche de l'égalité priori
cavaliers de 5 mai portant s'avère
tellement naturel que valeo 5
tout d'un coup les coûts de 100 chaînes
côté blanc alors surtout h6 il aurait
été naturel de faire bouger cette mais
j'imagine qu'après les champs d'angers 7
et des changes en c5
oui on a on a ici une très mauvaise
finale pour les noirs à cause du fou
c'est 8 du plan b qui peut pas bouger à
cause du cavaillé c6 tout d'un coup à
tomber c'est un peut arriver ok victoire
expéditive tandis que peut-être on peut
jeter un coup d'oeil aux matchs des
états unis et la victoire décisive de
délai m'accroche abri clé c'est irina
crouch qui l'emporté avec les noirs
ouais alors à temps elle joué contre un
jeu quand ça doit qu'à sauva voilà
facile parce qu'il se trouve que pour
trouver les joueuses pour trouver les
joueuses il faut connaître leur pseudo
alors il va falloir que j'aille à gg
normalement un endroit où loger les
pseudo je vais juste devoir trouver un
roman leur pseudo ok j'espère que je
vais réussir à trouver ça facilement
parce que les pseudos des matchs des
etats-unis contre le reste du monde nul
entre nakamura et rajab up nul entre
dominguez et fit ruzza qui route de la
star montante la partie c'est la
dernière partie qu'on a regardé tout à
l'heure nul entre sow et amine bassem et
donc on attend de voir avec impatience
la victoire d'hier in accrochage avec
les pièces noires qui apporte la
victoire aux états unis je vais pas lui
proposer de jouer pour eux c'est de
faire les parties mais je regardais sa
partie de soirée ça partirait à est donc
c'était contre dinara ça doit qu'à sera
donc tu vois le la victoire côté
américain était venu à être de leurs
points faibles entre guillemets alors de
leur point faible mais n'exagérons mais
effectivement il n'a crû que censé être
un petit peu moins forts que sont à
l'heure ça et à la vallée noire
alors là on peut en apprendre passé très
très vite il ya un sacrifice de pions un
petit peu spéculatif j'ai l'impression
pour les blancs avec 5 je sais pas trop
weiss g51 typique côté noir pour mettre
la pression sur le pion à f4 et à et
prendre la case de 5 et à l'envoyer à 5
dinars pour provoquer f5 et gagner la
case au 5 mai alors de là à jouer au
sein qui a donné deux pions
alors compris elle était de suite très
mal avec les blancs ouais je sais pas
trop ce qu'elle a raté parce que la
position ici et effectue des noms ont
rappelé un de plus la paire de fou ouais
j'ai absolument rien pour les voir juste
pour montrer le petit échec l'a donnée
par grand chose à madame b 8 force
échange de dahouët va avancer à partie
voir si c'est passé à
je sais juste un pion et irina qui ouais
non plus avoir la tacc maintenant au
tchad l'option qu'elle pouvait alors à
la ronde du pion mais alors quel centre
avec deux pions passé 10 et 5 à 4 le
cavalier un c4 une bonne pièce d'attac
contre b2 la position alors les blancs
opulents pas ch mais on sent que les
plans noirs sont quand même plus rapide
la coordination des pièces noires est
parfaite le roi est parfaitement protégé
c'est trop fort un regarde les pièces
marche sont trop fortes pas des
perpétuelles on va pouvoir parler compo
avec toi un romain du coup on va essayer
de s'imaginer dans la tête de gary
kasparov avec cette team europe
est-ce que tu utilises des remplaçants
est ce que tu reconduit une équipe qui
gagne
parce que là ça semble dommage de faire
sortir aronian qui a quand même réussi
une superbe fin de partie
maxime il n'en est pas question alors
d'où daoud oudeh vient quand même de
faire une assez mauvaise partie donc ça
dépend un petit peu de la physionomie
du match façon dauda voilà c'est un
joueur oui c'est un joueur qui va gagner
beaucoup plus souvent
donc il aurait les blancs on entre on
entend parler d'eux qu'ils auraient les
blancs au troisième et chic et donc duda
où ils rient et gris qui est peut-être
un tout petit peu plus fort que duda et
surtout beaucoup plus solide mais qui
gagnera sans doute moins deux parties il
en perdra parce qu'aucune avec les
blancs alors qu'avec duda tout est
possible parce que duda c'est un joueur
qui prend beaucoup de risques qui fait
beaucoup plus au spectacle
donc ça dépend un petit peu de la
physionomie du match
daisy très quoi tu saurais pas vraiment
t'aurais pas un avis tranché sur la
question
moi je remettrai duda mais voilà guiry
et pas internet a pas montré des
performances extraordinaires récemment
même s'il a battu magnus carlsen au
mieux son habitation
c'est le seul match qui l'a gagnée je
crois match qui doit gagner donnerait
plutôt sa chance à gouda à moins qu'ils
estiment vraiment avec une avec irina
coach qui vient de gagner en laçant en
forme
alors allez blanc entre musique zouk
voilà il faut quelque part il faut
quelques pas au gagner donc on aurait
vachier lagrave nakamura
ils ont cliqué en remplaçant les
amériques wesley so far west qu'elle
jouait déjà à l'horizon qu'ils ont qui
en plus de la raison caruana adacore
donc caruana qui va rentrer ouais
d'accord caruana qui va entraîner
évidemment donc ils peuvent faire une
équipe des américains à camurac à roanne
aso c'est difficile de faire mieux
so dominguez dominguez quinten tellement
fort joueurs rapides qu'eux
non mais ils ont ils ont vraiment 4 4
titulaires en vomissant ans 1 ouais et
des deux joueurs dominguez ou saut avec
les noirs les deux sont de toute façon
très solide
donc c'est pas facile de savoir où vous
mettre le point est ce que me dit tout
va contre des risques avec noir donc
après tu peux remettre nana commis hier
mais bon on en a qui a fait une mauvaise
partie hier qui s'est fait un peu balayé
par part joué john après jouer elle joue
9 celle ci s'est aussi associé d'une
avant tout meilleurs joueuses du monde
ces barricades ouais c'est un cadeau
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire est que
les composent sont tombés eux d'être un
petit peu miraculé donc je remettrai
duda et musette show qu'il faut dans ce
genre de combat de compétition après une
déception parce que la musique chaude
est forcément déçu de alors qu'on tente
pour son équipe mais déçu quand même ne
pas avoir gagné cette partie très
certainement il faut lui demander
comment elle se sent donc ce que voilà
il ya des joueurs qui après un résultat
décevant veulent absolument rejouer pour
se refaire il y en a d'autres qui peut
faire des c la place se reposer et
revenir donc ça ça dépend vraiment des
personnalités de chacun et c'est
évidemment le club item de l'équipe
guillaume garry kasparov qui va gérer ça
d'une façon alors on n'est pas là on
n'est pas là pour le voir alors est-ce
que ça va être est ce qu'il dit et ce
qui laisse la parole aux joueurs
ou est-ce qu'il est assez autoritaire
dans sa dans les compositions qui de
décomposition qu'il remet on peut pas le
savoir
toi tu as côtoyé en actions pion du
monde romain d'ailleurs tu as été assez
proche de veselin topalov qui a été
champion du monde
dans les années 2000 je sais plus quelle
année exact il était champion du monde
en 2005
donc oui alors c'était pas mais voilà
c'était pas le même topalov et kasparov
1 c'est un peu le même style sur
l'échiquier des doses étaient de grands
joueurs d'attac kasparov un cran au
dessus évidemment mais de grands joueurs
d' attaque sur l'échiquier mais des
personnalités très différentes avec top
à l'heure qui est quelqu'un de très doux
contrairement contrairement au premier
la première impression parfois qu'il
peut donner et kasparov qui est
quelqu'un de très agressif le chiffre
dans le sens combatif donc
donc il y aurait peut-être plutôt le
caractère à imposer imposer sa
composition enfin topal topalov je pense
topalov 6e et aurait peut pas trop le
cas pas trop le cas effectivement
kasparov topaloff
quand tu travailles avec lui du coup
qu'est ce que comme ce que tu peux nous
raconter rapidement ce que fait ce que
tu étais on peut dire l'équivalent de
son entraîneur pour pour faire une
analogie avec d'autres sports parce que
aux échecs on a un terme de seconde en
mai qui est assez spécifique aux échecs
on emploie le terme entraîneur pour que
tout le monde puisse bien comprendre
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aux échecs quand on
entraîne un joueur de ce calibre là
alors on fait beaucoup d'ouverture donc
et début de partie quand on vous voyez
quand on vous montrait des partis on
vous disait ça c'est la slave ça c'est
la green fade et c'est bon c'est parce
qu'il existe voilà comme ça des dizaines
et des dizaines d'ouverture différentes
et dans chacune de ces ouvertures il
existe des dizaines de variantes
différentes donc que le rôle de
l'entraîneur c'est de faire en sorte que
son joueur entre guillemets soit prêt
sur un maximum de choses et un très haut
niveau comme celui de cette nation scop
évidemment au niveau de topalov à
l'époque
évidemment tous les joueurs sont à peu
près près sur tout et donc vous allez
vous réussir à se démarquer il faut
essayer de travailler et d'aller plus
loin de chercher de nouvelles idées
s'ils sont assis son adversaire et
préparer jusqu'au 15e où il faut essayer
d'être prêt de paris jusqu'au 16e pour
le surprendre
mais voilà on ne sait jamais où la
préparation d'adversaires va s'arrêter
on peut être surpris parfois avant le
but d'une préparation le but d'un
entraîneur c'est de faire en sorte que
le joueur surprennent son adversaire en
premier donc comment tu fais pour pour
trouver ces surprises pour créer
surprise comment ça se passe du coup
concrètement ce boulot de préparateurs
d'ouverture on va dire alors quand on
travaille à la maison c'est complètement
autre chose que le jeu une partie de
compétition puisqu'on travaille avec
déjà on a une base avec des millions de
parties qui ont déjà été joués donc on a
déjà l'information de ce qui a été fait
par les autres ce qui est évidemment
très utile
il ya tout ce qui est il ya tout ce qui
a été publié du genre les livres les
revues etc tout ce qui est tout ce qui
est tout ce qui est déjà acquis comme on
va dire ceux des choses dont tout le
monde peut être au courant simplement en
lisant par exemple yves d'échec
ensuite il ya les modules d'analysé donc
c'est à dire que par exemple on a une
position comme ça on branche
l'ordinateur de alors là c'est la
position initiale mais on branche
l'ordinateur sur une position et
l'ordinateur va nous dire ici le
meilleur coup c'est ça sauf que si vous
mettez un ordinateurs peu puissants que
vous laisse y réfléchir quelques
secondes il aura très certainement tort
si vous mettez un ordinateur très très
puissant pendant à tourner assez
longtemps on peut faire confiance à son
jugement et donc voilà le relais
ce qui est difficile dans le fait de
trouver une nouvelle idée c'est que tout
le monde peut faire la même chose
tout le monde a les mêmes bases de
données tout le monde a les mêmes
modules mobiles d' analyse donc ce sont
ces fameux ces fameux femmes ces fameux
logiciel qui nous disent qu'ils aient
mieux pourquoi comment tout le monde
tout le monde peut faire le même travail
donc que la question c'est qui phrase ce
travail le mieux et qui va être capable
peut-être d'apporter quelque chose en
plus de ce que l'ordinateur et des
parties déjà joué peuvent nous apporter
par exemple essayer d'aller à l'encontre
de des choix de l'ordinateur essayer de
trouver les différents de plus fort quoi
ou de plus embêtant au moins que
l'adversaire n'aura pas prévu pour
pourvoir le surprendre puisque voilà
tous les joueurs sont préparés se
prépare travail à la maison et donc ont
toutes un appel un répertoire
d'ouvertures donc ils savent quoi je le
répertoire d'ouvertures s'est posée
ouverture vos débuts de partie avec les
blancs et les noirs donc ils en ont ils
sont dans tous un répertoire
d'ouvertures très élaborés et donc les
surprendre c'est pas facile et c'est là
qu'il faut pousser le plus loin possible
avec les modules les plus fortes
possibles et aussi avec avec sa tête
parce que c'est pas les ordinateurs qui
font tous donc essayé voilà par exemple
de trouver un endroit où l'ordinateur
sous-estiment quelque chose ou
l'ordinateur se trompe ou alors où
l'ordinateur imac août l'ordinateur
estime comme mauvais peut-être peut-être
pour de bonnes raisons mais qui votent
très très difficile à trouver sur
l'échiquier pour un joueur humain
donc voilà c'est c'est du travail en
permanence et être l'entraîneur d'un
joueur de haut niveau
c'est beaucoup de boulot en général c
c'est du travail
on va dire 16 heures par jour pendant un
tournoi peut-être plus parfois surtout
ça dépend ça les pensées les plans de la
facilité des problèmes à résoudre mais
ça peut arriver de se mettre à
travailler
l'après-midi pour la partie du lendemain
et de travailler jusqu'à la partie du
lendemain si on n'arrive pas à trouver
les solutions
si on n'arrive pas tout et les idées qui
en voudrait trouver pendant un tournoi
l'entraîneur travaillent plus que le
joueur et ça te représente combien
d'heures de travail par jour pour
l'entraîneur or tournoi alors tournoi
c'est assez c'est beaucoup plus détendu
en général ce sont des sessions
d'entraînement
donc moi par exemple quand j'étais avec
topalov c'était assez tranquille ils ont
commencé ont commencé en matinée à une
heure à une heure raisonnable dit son
heure voilà ont travaillé de trois
heures l'accès en était un et en espagne
donc ils habitent en espagne c'est un
peu aussi
c'est leur espagnol s'est un peu décalé
voilà ont travaillé pendant deux trois
heures à un moment donné en un mot
d'honneur prenez un café ensuite on peut
déjeuner déjeuner rapidement on
retravaille et 4 5 heures voilà
éventuellement une petite une petite
balade un petit point sur ce qu'on a vu
la journée et ça s'arrêtait là mg en
général le soir après je vérifier avec
l'ordinateur des choses qu'on a vues
vais travailler parce que des sessions
d'entraînement c'est voilà c'est d'être
2 sur un échiquier donc de trouver un
maximum d'idées
pendant ces sessions d'entraînement pour
le joueur le travail de mémoire parce
qu'on en parle est un petit peu avec
fabien hier mais moi il me semble que
ces joueurs du haut niveau ont une
mémoire hors du commun et qui
réussissent à ingurgiter des fichiers
d'une taille
incroyable au vu de la profondeur de
leur analyse quel est ton avis tour en
tant qu'entraîneur risques et étaient
parfois surpris de la mémoire d'un
joueur comme topalov white swallow fait
partie des jeux accords qui ont une
excellente mémoire
oui j'étais très surpris parfois ils
disaient parfois on s'appelait une
dizaine tiens il ya trois ans du trapel
ce fichier que tu m'as fait à ce moment
là il y avait ici et ça et je me
rappelle pas du tout de quelques
fichiers parlait donc j'étais obligé de
jeu rouvray pour voir évidemment trois
ans après c'est pas grave hein c'est pas
une faute professionnelle bien mais
humblement j'étais impressionné de voir
à quel point il se rappelait de hits rap
et de tout ce qu'on avait fait alors que
moi des trucs que j'avais fait pour lui
quelques années auparavant des fois et
c'est la difficulté pour les joueurs de
haut niveau on parlait de maxime tout à
l'heure qui changent change assez peu
d'ouverture mais c'est qu'il ya déjà
tellement de choses à se rappeler quand
on joue une seule ouverture parce qu'il
est blanc peut jouer aux quatre des
quatre c4 cavaliers f3 et c est jacques
avec les noirs il faut avoir une
ouverture sur chaque premier coup blanc
avec les blancs quand on joue à quatre
ou des quatre il faut avoir
il faut être préparé sur n'importe
quelle ouverture que choisit les noirs
donc en fait il ya déjà tel en ayant
seulement un seul répertoire
d'ouvertures en ayant seulement un choix
l'ouverture sur chaque possibilité
advert il ya déjà tellement de choses à
savoir qu'effectivement ça demande une
très bonne mémoire et c'est pour ça que
des joueurs qui ont vraiment une mémoire
extraordinaire peuvent se permettre plus
facilement d'avoir plusieurs ouvertures
d'autres préfèrent se concentrer sur ce
qu'ils connaissent bien et essayer de
s'en rappeler ne jamais se tromper et
alors qu'est ce qui fait la différence
entre un joueur comme toi qui arrive et
on le disait tout à l'heure aux
alentours de la 40e place mondiale ce
qui est déjà un niveau juste
impressionnant que les gens imaginent
si vous faites un rapport avec le tennis
par exemple qui est aussi un sport
individuel aux alentours de la 40e place
mondiale
ça tape déjà assez bien qu'est ce qui
fait la différence après justement entre
ces 40e place mondiale 50e mondial et le
top 10 et le top 10 on va dire c'est on
parlait de la mémoire est ce que c'est
ce que c'est la mémoire est ce que c'est
la vitesse de calcul est ce que c'est le
mental est ce que c'est un peu de tout
en fait mais et aux échecs comme au
tennis l'écart entre la 40e et la
première place mondiale est bien plus
gros qu entre la 80e aide à la 40e
plus voilà plus on se rapproche de la
première place plus les échelons sont
difficiles à gravir et voilà ce qui fait
la différence est effectivement bon bah
ya le travail évidemment mais il ya
aussi il ya aussi le talent déjà pour
commencer et puis voilà l'homme le
mental la psychologie le temps qu'on
passe le temps dédié aux échecs
cet arrêt il faut avoir ça dans la peau
il faut il faut être capable de ne pas
craquer pendant une partie qui durent
parfois 5h 6h il faut être capable de
tenir le coup parce que la différence
entre les échecs et par exemple le
tennis pour revenir au tennis c'est que
au tennis si vous avez un moment de
faiblesse et que vous envoyer une balle
dans le filet c'est juste un point alors
ça peut être un point qui vous coûte 1 7
admettons mais ça reste un set vous
pouvez pas perdre le match juste sur une
seconde d'inattention ou alors si vous
avez déjà perdu un set avant bon aux
echets vous pouvez vraiment dominé de a
à z c'est à dire que c'est comme si vous
veniez 6 0 5 0 40 0 et qu'en faisant une
erreur vous perdiez le match ça c'est ce
qui peut se passer aux échecs donc c'est
la difficulté du jeu en tant
qu'entraîneur du coup est ce que
n'importe quel bon joueur d'échecs du
haut niveau ferait un bon entraîneur ou
sa demande d'égalité vraiment différente
là pour l'appel sa demande d sa demande
des qualités différentes après je sais
pas si chacun que ce se conditionner
comme il faut il ya aussi fait
l'entraînent quelqu'un peut dossier est
un bon entraîneur pour un certain profil
de joueur à un mauvais entraîneur pour
un pour un autre pour un autre profil de
joueur c'est à dire qu'il faut vraiment
qu une entente qui ne compte qu'une
compatibilité et c'est pareil au tennis
en a donc voix des grands joueurs de
tennis qui disent vraiment d'entraîneur
il est très bon mais on s'entendait pas
ça n'est pas close échec voilà il faut
vraiment avec topalov on s'entendait
aussi très bien on s'entendait très bien
sûr le sur le côté professionnel sur les
haies sur des chics et c'est à dire que
regarder dans la même direction je
savais qu'il voulait
ac et prendre des risques c'est prendre
des risques et c'est donc je travaillais
dans la direction qu'il voulait on
s'entendait aussi bien sur le point
d'être sur le point de vue personnel et
du cou et du coup voilà ça a aidé et il
ya besoin d'une certaine complicité pour
pour les échecs pour être l'entraîneur
d'un grand toit il faut un gros niveau
échec bien évidemment pour avoir des
beautés les idées mais aussi une
complicité au niveau du style de jeu et
du caractère donc ça doit pas être
évident de trouver son oui c'est ça
qu'il faut savoir trouver les mots si
jamais une partie se passe mal par
exemple il faut que le joueur soit
content de retrouver son entraîneur
quand ça quand la partie se passe mal il
ya des jeux il ya des joueurs qui sont
connues par exemple pour passer leurs
nerfs sur leur entraîneur après voilà
s'ils perdent s'y perdre une partie
ça va être la faute des entraîneurs etc
par exemple topalov c'était pas du tout
le style
au contraire ils allaient mais même s'il
était déçu un jour d'une partie ils
allaient voilà il allait en parler
calmement et puis allez dire allez on va
dîner etc y avait pas ça ça remet tait
pas en cause votre relation humaine ou
le fait que tourne autour du soleil quoi
ça va non pas du tout non donc partir du
moment où on s'entendait bien sur le
plan personnel s'ils vont s'il ya un
moment donné si je commence à faire des
erreurs dans mes préparations là oui je
me serais fait forcément je me serais
fait virer mais voilà c'est pas voilà
c'est pas c'est pas arrivé ou très très
peu souvent et du coup voilà on était
voilà moi j'étais très content de
travailler pour lui et lui a priori
était tout cas je l'espère arrêté je
pense qu'on tende mois voilà j'ai écrit
par exemple un livre sur mes années avec
lui et j'ai écrit la préface donc voilà
ça montre qu'on toujours aujourd'hui on
s'entend bien
ouais tu as écrite et auteur aussi
d'ailleurs on n'a pas parlé parce qu'on
revenait sur le côté entraîneurs
kasparov etc
mais au delà d'être d'être entraîneur
c'est aussi un auteur assez prolifique
et ça me ça me faisait tout à l'heure
quand tu parles est qu une partie
d'échecs pouvait se perdre sur un coût
puisque tu as une série de livres assez
connu sur les erreurs évitables aux
échecs essai souffrant d'éclat justement
que tu mettre la balle dans le filet si
je peux me permettre de l'année
jce oui manuel des erreurs évitables aux
échecs c'est vrai que c'est
eh ben ça fait mais ça fait partie des
choses que j'explique dans le livre
aussi qu'il faut qu'il faut après qu'il
faut être capable de se reprendre après
une erreur quoi parce qu'en général
quand même une erreur nous coûte pas
moins que ça serait une erreur
gravissime
une seule erreur suffit pas perdre la
partie mes échecs sont un jour un jeu
tellement tellement fort en émotion et
en émotions tellement dur
psychologiquement que parfois la
tendance quand on fait une erreur et
qu'on s'en rend compte en faire deux
puis trois puis quatre
et voilà ça c'est des choses c'est des
choses par exemple qu'un joueur de très
haut niveau peut-être est capable et
capable d'éviter il est peut-être c'est
aussi la différence entre un joueur de
très haut niveau et un joueur de très
haut niveau c'est celui qui va être
capable quand il fut une erreur de
revoilà donc je reprends je reprend là
où j'en étais tant pis j'ai fait une
erreur je reprends je reprends la tête
la tête froide reprendre 0 et givet quoi
je ne sais pas de bidouiller pour
essayer de rattraper mon erreur parce
qu'en général la après ça s'enchaîne et
la partie est perdue
alors on a les compos qui ont été
données et écoute kasparov qui s'est pas
cassé la tête il a fait exactement la
même chose qui hier c'est à dire de
remplacer duda par guy et bouzid chopard
manade admise est je trouve que c'est un
peu un choix par défaut la de
l'entraîneur quand même qui fait deux
fois la même chose à la presse que c'est
son plan de toujours faire ça alors
écoute il fait reposer
duda vient de faire une mauvaise partie
alors pourquoi ne pas le faire
sa part assez logique de le faire se
reposer mais j'ai été choqué sur une
déception donc pourquoi pas vers ces
choix sont tout à fait vrai nom comprend
aussi incompréhension sur une compo
genre m j'aurais j'aurais mis duda avec
les blancs mais ouais c'est vrai mais ça
guérit en plus il a déçu hier il a perdu
une partie je crois que c'était contre
liu yang avec les blancs où il s'est
vraiment fait marcher dessus face à l'as
petrov de son adversaire mais peut-être
ils veulent relancer aussi pour la suite
de la compétition parce qu'à force de ne
pas le faire jouer si tu ne fais plus
jamais rang
et c'est fini oui mais s'il vient donc
du coup il a perdu avec les blancs elle
elle le fera a ajouté blanc ceci sahara
est ok donc ils essayent de leurs il
essaie de le remettre en confiance
mais voilà wesley sourd et donc ils vont
pas jouer caruana aujourd'hui les
américains qui ont décidé de se passer
du numéro deux mondial
alors ça oui c'est bizarre comme choix
ils font entrer ils sortent irina cruche
qui vient de gagner pour faire jouer aux
attentes ce qui qui est quand même
ballack bon ok pas qui est pas si loin
des niveaux d'hier une accroche que
c'est bizarre de faire sortir une chose
qui vient de gagner je trouve
ouais cdc des choix après un qui sont
qui sont faits par par le coach et
donaldson je crois l'entraîneur
sélectionneur de l'équipe américaine qui
a fait ce choix étrange que quand j'ai
dû wesley so 3 je viens il a mis la
composition entre guillemets classique
de l'équipe des états unis mais en
réalité non il a gardé 2000 gazar moi
j'attends quand même quand je vois ce
genre de choses romain devoir vraiment
l'équipe qui joue je me dis est-ce que
c'est pas la personne l'informaticien de
fusée qui remplit les compos qui a fait
une erreur
la tension dominguez c'est dans les
magasins rapide c'est vraiment
dominguez en rapide c'est vraiment un
c'est du très lourd
c'est du très très lourd un cador
beaucoup plus quand déjà un cadeau en
cadence lente mais de vraiment très très
fort en rapide en blitz en billes se
croit un peu moins rapides l'un des tout
meilleurs joueurs du monde
non il est il est vraiment sont vraiment
monstrueux à ces américains qui ont
vraiment de la qualité à profusion 1
effectivement au final en fait c'est
peut-être en fait car à wana et
peut-être simplement quatrième meilleur
joueur de l'équipement rapide sur sur
internet agréé amour à contesta
dominguez un très fort joueur rapide
saut il terminait à tous les atouts les
grandes chez ce tour est terminé devant
devant caruana tous les grands chefs
tour en tout cas en rapide donc donc
après tous si ils font pas jouer kawana
c'est peut-être tout simplement qu'ils
estiment que après après il a fait 2 sur
2 hier comme nous dit sun révèle il a il
a fait demi finale du magnus
invitationnal en tenant dans les rapides
contre l'as cannes murat le cas le
caruana qu'ont donné qu'on donnait
perdant à 10 contre 1 en finale de
championnat du monde contre contre carl
scène au départage c'est plus le carreau
banal aujourd'hui il a beaucoup
progressé en rapide ça c'est sûr après
je ne sais pas quelle est la compo
exactement lol c'est à dire lors des
échiquiers des états unis faudrait
regarder parce que c'est normalement
caruana logique de lui donner tellement
bien préparés sur lattes et logique de
le mettre aux deux avec les blancs
contre à rognan écoute c'est un choix
bizarre on nous dit alors que dans le
chat on a une info de quelqu'un de
confiance qui nous dit que
irina croche sort d'une copie de 19 donc
du pardon irene a crush oui où
rien n'apparaît sur les réseaux sociaux
effectivement donc
donc c'est vrai que si elle a eu
coronavirus peut-être que physiquement
elle est pas encore remise à 100% c'est
que ce virus peut faire peut faire des
dégâts et peut-être jusqu'à n'a pas le
jus pour pour jouer deux parties
d'échecs de haut niveau actuellement ça
pour ça pourrait expliquer en tout cas
le choix du coach mais margot gnian
gnian gnian écoute ça pue le remettre
dedans la victoire ça traduit redonner
le sourire en tout cas ce joli piège là
qu'il a pu faire avec le b 4 qui finira
dans un thé manuel j'imagine ça finira
dans un ça finira dans un livre parce
que c'est tellement instructive secoue
b4 effectivement un coup typique en plus
dans ce genre de finale de foot couleurs
opposées mais là la paralysie de toutes
les pièces adverse on s'est vraiment
très très joli ce qu'il a fait dans
cette partie oui c'était vraiment bien
bien réaliser ça ça nous a sauvé un on
va pas commencer depuis cinq minutes il
me semble kevin alors je vois pas tous
les joueurs en fait je vois pas une
veille si je suis en train de d'accord
ce qui me semble qu'on devait commencer
à 45 et qu'ils écoutent mes jeux en fait
j'ai oublié de le dire mais ils ont fait
un changement d'horaire et ils ont
décidé de changer l'horaire de toutes
les deux toutes les journées d'accord et
du coup en réalité ça va commencer à 17
heures d'accord mais bon je me méfie
toujours quand même tu sais entre
l'heure théorique de début fait leur
réelle de début il peut y avoir une
différence
on peut y avoir une différence
je suis en train pendant que pendant que
ça se prépare de préparer les caméras en
amont ok mais ça va pas être facile
ce qui à l arbitre en réalité tu vois il
ya une conférence zoom pour expliquer un
petit peu aux gens comment ça se passe
il ya une conférence sur le logiciel
zoom ou les joueurs ont tous leurs
caméras allumées ainsi que leur partage
d'écran donc l' arbitre peut avoir
l'écran de chaque joueur et leur caméra
pendant toute la durée de la partie
seulement évidemment entre les parties
les joueurs étaient leurs caméras ils
partirent viennent donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai des petits problèmes pour
recadrer parce que les gentils partis
reviennent donc il faut à chaque fois
bien bien remettre les caméras comme
elles doivent l'être mais voilà
l'arbitré et surveille en fait hein tu
vois moi je le vois en fait sur sur
l'autre écran il était bien concentré il
regarde bien tous les écrans comme il
faut pour être sûr que les joueurs
n'ouvre pas d'autres programmes et
qu'ils soient bien uniquement sur sur
leur partie parce que je pense qu'ils
ont plusieurs caméras en tout cas
c'était le chaos magnus invitationnal je
pense qu'il y avait plusieurs
je suis même sûr qu'ils avaient
plusieurs caméras dans les appartements
ou les maisons de chacun des joueurs
puisque maxime me disait par exemple que
le soir il devait enregistrer que ça
prenait quelques heures a tout
enregistré toutes envoyées et alors les
crues des mesures anti triche
effectivement ces fameux module
d'analysé dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
qui peut qui elle a travaillé c'est
évidemment il est évidemment strictement
interdit de les utiliser pendant ses
propres parties ce sont des modules qui
sont là pour pour aider à travailler ou
pour jouer entre eux mais c'est
évidemment de la triche de les utiliser
pendant les parties et donc c'est pour
ça que voilà qu'on demande aux joueurs
de mettre des caméras sans doute sous
plusieurs angles pour être sûr que voilà
qui a personne qui est là pour pour
donner un coup que le je regarde pas
l'ordinateur mais aussi donc il ya
personne pour regarder l'ordinateur à la
place du joueur et lui dire quoi faire
on voit des mesures anti triche
tout simplement ils avaient
hmm hmm des micros ali mellah pendant
les parties les micros des joueurs
étaient allumées pour vérifier qu'on
n'entende pas de personnes dans la pièce
vous avez remarqué qu'ils n'ont pas de
casque sur les oreilles pas de pas
d'écouteurs ils sont vraiment surveiller
ils sont vraiment surveiller romain et
c'est logique parce que cet homme facile
de tricher aux échecs que c'est très
bien que toutes ces mesures soient mises
en place
c'est plus facile pour les pour les
tournois pour le tournant avec comment
dire pour les tournois sur internet
puisque voilà des arbitres et des
détecteurs de métaux et ça suffit mais
là quand les joueurs changent elles sont
chez eux effectivement sa demande
quelques petites vérification ouais et
la sema on assiste avant les parties
l'ennoyage assists de mon côté au moment
où on voit l'appartement des joueurs or
voilà appartement on voit pas grand
chose mais l'artiste qui demande aux
joueurs de prendre leurs caméras et de
bien devient tournée de bien vérifier
que les personnes autour d'eux après on
leur fait quand même confiance mais ça
permet de dissiper tous les doutes un
oui absolument toute façon dans tout le
temps dans ses compositions il ya que
deux que des personnes de confiance 1
mais bon évidemment on sait jamais une
autre petite mesure entre guillemets qui
a été prise pour éviter la tentation
c'est que le plus gros du prize pool qui
est de 190 milles 180 mille dollars par
don pour ce tournoi va être distribué
aux joueurs
indépendamment du résultat de chaque
équipe il ya qu un petit bonus de 24
mille dollars pour les vainqueurs et
douze mille dollars pour les finalistes
mais je veux dire par là que
voilà le gros du prix est donnée de
manière équitable à tous pour éviter que
les joueurs puissent avoir la tentation
de trouver des manières très sophistiqué
de tricher comme ça au moins c'est c'est
tranquille c'est tranquille romain est
ce que toi tu as déjà eu affaire à faire
face un tricheur dans une partie
officielle
oui au moins une fois au moins une fois
en général en général on s'en rend pas
compte en fait la partie se passe mal on
se dit simplement qu'on a mal joué et
c'est seulement après en vérifiant ou en
quelqu'un qui nous faisait défaut à
défaut quelques quelques mois après ça
peut être tout de suite après la partie
ça peut être quelques mois plus tard ça
m'est arrivé au moins une fois je pense
deux fois tu vis tu vis avec entre
guinée c'est la vie est foutue avec en
fait c'est mieux ne pas le savoir mais à
côté il faut que évidemment la fraîcheur
il faut il faut absolument arrêter tout
de suite pour qu'il fasse pas d'autres
d'autres victimes
mais bon voilà une défaite sociale mais
une défaite une défaite contre un
tricheur c'est vraiment bon d'un côté on
dit que c'est pas sa faute mais genre
d'échec on réfléchit pas comme ça en
tout cas que c'est vraiment le résultat
qui compte et se dire du coup c'est pas
ça ne nous console pas se dire bon bah
c'est pas ma faute c'est pas moi qui ai
mal joué au contraire ça nous frus de se
dire en fait que j'ai perdu cette partie
je suis me suis concentré pendant des
heures en fait qui est en train de jouer
comme quelqu'un qui triche et j'avais
aucune chance donc c'est vraiment aucune
consolation dans le fait de savoir que
l'adversaire adversaire la triche et oui
il faut il faut dire qu aux échecs là le
gros problème par rapport à ça c'est que
contrairement au dopage dans le sport
qui donne un simple avantage en réalité
là n'importe quel internaute qui
regarderait les partis s'ils utilisaient
une aide extérieure pourrait très
facilement battre le champion du monde
alors après l'excité détecte un
généralement mai
mais c'est vrai que c'est c'est une aide
juste énorme c'est pas comme un petit
moteur dans un vélo on va nous par
exemple avec toi romain si on va faire
le tour de france avec un tout petit
moteur ça va pas nous servir à grand
chose
non par contre si on va jouer en l2
championnat du monde avec un ordinateur
on va devenir champion du monde d'échecs
oui oui que la différence c'est que
c'est pas c'est pas de ce pain simple un
simple petit bush d'avoir d'avoir l'aide
de l'ordinateur c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment une autriche trop trop grave
j'ai une triche qui qui assure la
victoire un tout simplement oui c'est la
grosse différence du coût entre entre
les échecs et les autres les autres
disciplines pour pour ce volet là mais
là dans ce tournoi là de toute façon
même nous en tant qu' en tant que
professionnel entre guillemets on voit
bien ça on voit bien là les parties
convoi honnêtement on voit bien qu'il
n'ya pas il n'ya pas anguille sous roche
un nom est de toute façon il faut pas
voir les échecs comme un comme un sport
de triche c'est quelque chose de très
rare on parle de 0,01 pour cent des
joueurs peut-être
voilà c'est quelque chose mais c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut éradiquer parce
que même s'il s'est même si très peu de
monde
très peu de monde ferait une chose pas
et que de tricher pendant une partie
d'échecs et bah il faut il y en a quand
même qui sont en a quand même qui vont
le faire
en général ce sont des gens qui aiment
pas spetième sûr qu'ils soient qu'ils
ont les moyens financiers soient qui
n'aime pas ce mot d échec plus que ça
qu'ils ont simplement choisi choisi un
sport dans lequel dans lequel ils
peuvent tricher et mais voilà c'est
extrêmement rare et d'un des tournois
dans des tournois de haut niveau comme
on est en train de regarder la voilà il
pourrait n'y avoir aucune protection il
y aurait quand même
aucune triche
là vraiment avec des joueurs comme ça en
réalité oui tu aurais pas vraiment
besoin de mode de protection
mais voilà quand même comme l'avait dit
comme l'avait dit les organisateurs
c'est plus pour rassurer c'est plus pour
rassurer tout le monde que vraiment pour
on a tout ça c'est de toute façon une
obligation on peut pas baser on peut pas
baser [ __ ] d'un championnat du monde
des nations super par internet sur sur
la confiance qu'on donne aux joueurs
même s'ils ont même si on a une
confiance totale en tout ces joueurs se
mesurent la sont nécessaires un tout
simplement oui non sap est apparue de
rassurer tout le monde ne pas avoir de
doutes et de jouer de jouer avec
l'esprit tranquille et aussi où il
devait être ce petit volet quand même
officiel puisque c'est c'est une
compétition sous l'égide de la fidh donc
c'est pas c'est pas n'importe quoi et il
a suffi que je cadre absolument toutes
les caméras avec je te dise romain on va
repartir pour que l'arbitré décidé pour
pour cette dernière ronde de se mettre à
la caméra mais il va peut-être partir
mais on va voir
sinon je vais être obligé de refaire ce
tour first 2 0 parce que là on va la
revue de ce soir oui je le vois je voi
arbitres l'arbitré l'habitude peut-être
ce n'est juste à la caméra en début de
partie pour dire pour rappeler les
règles à tout le monde et peut-être
qu'il va serait enlevé ou peut-être
qu'il va décider que qu'il a envie qu'il
a envie d'être à la caméra aussi un nom
il est reparti il est reparti l'arbitré
du mans il est parti alors ça c'est pas
guéri c'est la trame eleven aronian il
est marrant cet arbitre je vous
montrerai être pour une prochaine
journée
il est assez marrant non mais il a l'air
tranquille
il rigole assez souvent bonne atmosphère
atmosphère donc les bonnes qui était
notre notre sauveur dans le match
précédent
aussi il a réussi à trouver de réussir à
trouver des ressources dans cette
position où on pensait que penser que la
mule sera déjà un bon résultat mais ces
joueurs là ont tellement de classe sur
un échiquier que voilà tout moment à
tout moment ça peut une petite
inattention et hop voilà le joueur
adverse qui sont enfermés sont fous sur
la casse ces deux comme on l'a vu et hop
à rené ans qui en a profité tout de
suite mais c'est la lumière bleue aussi
les romains mais c'est vrai que c'est
très bleu je crois qu'il ya une lumière
bleue
c'est ça qui fait la différence ça doit
être ça a donné des idées originales
cette lumière bleue pas c'est sympa que
font que font les arbitres qu'est ce que
c'est que pour une vie dans le chat peut
être l'arbitré qui est vraiment à la
bien pour cette ronde et qui autorise la
trique
aïe aïe aïe
mais savait que cette lumière bleue
séparant je sais pas je n'ai jamais vu
ça l'incendié dans une discothèque quoi
oui alors à temps est-ce que sa part ça
devrait partir d'une seconde à l'autre
ses 107 17 heures il est 17h un tu vois
tout à l'heure quand on était tranquille
ça commençait à l'heure ses doigts c'est
notre c'est notre karma romain c'est
notre karma
là on est au taquet y aura deux trois
minutes de retard
on va s'en remettre
effectivement on est impatient que
partie commence oui ça doit être
j'imagine la petite vérification tu sais
que j'ai vu avec les arbitres avant les
parties comme j'étais attentif
j'imagine qu'elles qu'elles existent
dans tous les salons donc c'est vrai que
qui peut y avoir un petit est un peu le
discours de leur vie d'avant match quoi
ça peut ne pas ne pas se terminer
exactement même moment où peut-être
qu'un arbitre qui n'est pas acquis n'est
pas content d'une un 360° avec la caméra
ou quoi et ça peut faire prendre un peu
de retard
c'est normal c'est normal effectivement
donc en fait oui donc donc comme on
disait donc des caméras sous plusieurs
angles
et les arbitres qui avant chaque partie
donc iphone briefing d'avant match je
vais essayer je vais demander demain si
je peux vous le faire et je vous le
ferez on pourra le faire entre les
rondes le petit briefing c'est vrai que
c'était très sympa à voir si briefing de
larbitre alors on a fait quoi au premier
match et ben écoute on a gagné le
torture 50 a gagné deux et demi un et
demi grâce à une victoire d'un rognant
victoire qui nous fait plaisir
arnaud voilà donc on rappelle que qui
vit une période difficile et qui suit
ensuite un problème familial et qui
voilà qui est qui fait son retour dans
la compétition et donc voilà non mais ça
fait vraiment plaisir de salsa fait
vraiment doublement plaisir romain à le
voir gagner 1 franchement au-delà de au
delà de l'équipe d'europe qu'on soutient
ça fait vraiment plaisir de voir ce
joueur gagnant j'aurais presque étaient
contents qu'ils nous battent ils étaient
dans l'équipe adverse honnêtement je
suis d'accord avec toi
voilà surtout que c'est quelqu'un de
très très sympa à rognan ouais non
vraiment sympa y savent ça fait ça fait
vraiment chaud au coeur de voir qu'ils
reprennent la compétition alors qu'on va
avoir directement on va sûrement se
concentrer en premier lieu sur cette
partie puisqu'on va avoir un choc un
classique des échecs sur internet avec
notre numéro un français et meneur de
l'équipe européenne maxime vachier
lagrave contre hikaru nakamura qui bat
sur internet s'ils avaient pas magnus
carlsen y gagnerait tous les tournois
hikaru nakamura qui nous a faits qui
nous a fait beaucoup de mal an prochain
les gains j'en parlais hier nous en
avait parlé à qui on n'a qu'a acquis qui
nous a battus un par un jusqu'à jusqu'à
éliminer maxime est enfin
ouais c'est vrai
on peut on peut leur dire une petite
prodige à 6 et une autre compétition sur
internet par équipe donc on joue pour
l'équipe de france romain qui est un
titulaire en puissance de l'équipe et
qui jouait pas du coup ce match à
élimination mais qui suivaient les
commentaires et ça tu m'écris vers le
soir on s'est écrit vers une heure du
matin tu m'a écrit on n'arrivait pas à
dormir soit onze mois
on n'en dormais pas de ses victoires de
nakamura qui nous avait tous battus à
lui tout seul
effectivement parce qu'il ya un match de
match de les partager à la fin d'un
amour as they retrouver est obligé de
faire 4 sur 4 temps de faire trois sur
trois pour pour la qualification de son
équipe une seule nul nous aurait
qualifiés et il nous a tous eu il ya eu
d'abord yannick c'est ça ensuite maxime
lagarde a ensuite lauton maxime maxime
vachier lagrave vrai qu'on a là à
l'écran et savez que c'est une défaite
qui l'avait été dur d'avaler un s'était
pas ce n'était pas évident mais bon sens
et remy finalement mais ce n'est pas
qu'un murat qui est encore là
aujourd'hui de nouveau en face de nous
commençons à voir un petit peu marre et
c'est maxime réussi se voit là pour
l'équipe d'europe là à lui montré un peu
qui est le patron finalement parce que
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que d'un
camion puis ça d'assez bons résultats
sur internet contre maxime gagné gagne
assez souvent
voilà la maxime a choisi une approche
une approche solide on a un lot gambie
dame habituel de nakamura une position
voile avec un petit avantage des espaces
pour les blancs en principe le principe
c'est sans risque et les noirs voilà
toujours en fait le même problème que
tout à l'heure avec ce fou c'est 8,7
problème si les noirs si les noirs
avaient déjà baissé sous bessette
ici tout ira bien mais là les blancs
veulent essayer par exemple de jouer
cavalier des six gagnés la paire de fou
et de jouer bas je joue avec cet
avantage et la paire de fou dont on a
déjà parlé plusieurs fois
aujourd'hui donc voilà deux fous contre
soi de cavaliers soif ou cavaliers ouais
ça pourrait ça pourrait faire mal si on
réussissait à prendre ce fou en tout cas
donner un petit avantage à long terme à
maxime et c'est tout ce qu'ils cherchent
un maxime des petits avant
à long terme contre hikaru il faut pas
jouer de position trop compliqué parce
qu'il est extrêmement dangereux dans le
jeu tactique
par contre si maxime pouvait avoir un
petit avantage il peut il pleut la sub
supérieur pourrait arriver à bien
torturé effectivement ouais c'est ce qui
va chercher à le joueur français c'est
un assez bon choix je pense qu'on est
assez assez content de l'ouverture ici
côté européen
romain alors ça va dépendre un petit peu
des prochains coups mais j'ai
l'impression qu'ici il peut jouer
cavalier des six par exemple et s'il
arrive à prendre
c'est d'ailleurs en un fou il devrait
être un peu mieux
à moins que à moins qu'ils se contentent
de jouer à tout 17 et sur qui est tombée
cette tu veux faire dame b 6
mais je commence quelques petits soucis
qui a aidé tour des huit d'accord ça
doit être ça l'idée de nakamura donc mon
coup qu'à aider si ce n'est peut-être
pas brillant donc peut-être simplement
alors madame f3 quelque chose comme ça
pour rejouer pour l'espace on garde les
dames on joue sur un avantage des
espaces sur le plan b 7 juste pour
expliquer pour prendre une petite
photographie tu sais pour pour expliquer
à tout le monde ce genre de position
l'avantagent des plans si on arrivait
une position comme celle ci il est il
est clair on a trois pièces quand même
développé est bien placé un qui rayonne
alors que côté noir et bien simplement
la position est symétrique au niveau des
pions à quelque chose près mais à part
ce pion qui ont à 3,4 mais ça change pas
grand chose mais le placement de pièces
c'est pas du tout de même
romain côté noir absolument à l'eau
chaude est le fou c'est 8 qui pour
l'instant
dans le cas des pas encore développé
dans encore dépendent des pions bessette
et la tour blanche qui s'apprête à
surgir en d1 l'autre en c1
on va mettre les tours au centre là
effectivement ça toutes les pièces
blanches sont supérieurs aux pièces
noires il faudra ici avec baignoire pour
ne pas voir problème il faudrait pouvoir
en un seul coup faire fous ces six ici
c'est à dire pour pouvoir jouer fou 17
pouces et six en un seul coup le
problème c'est que sur tous les sets
déjà et a plombé cet ensuite il ya tout
rêve d un plusieurs petits problèmes
je pense que l'idée de jouer deux coups
de feu d'affilée larbi 30 à parler dans
le temps le meeting avant parce que
c'est écrit
concrètement dans les règles des échecs
et je crois en principe il doit être
écrit oui c'est d'abord aux blancs et
ensuite au noir savait que là ça aurait
été marrant j'ai pas pu entendre le
discours de l'art vite mais c'est vrai
que si ça faisait partie du discours ça
aurait pu être drôle donc dans l'effroi
jouer coûte maxime qui suit qui suit
l'idée que tu nous que tu nous donnais
pour les blancs et les blancs c'est vrai
qu'ils ont ce petit avantage là et
écoute ça se passe plutôt bien ça fait
plaisir c'est qu'on parle de deux coups
d'affilée cela me rappelle que j'ai déjà
vu j'ai déjà vu quelqu'un a essayé de
faire ça j'ai déjà vu un être est
retombé mais son adversaire n'avait pas
encore vu et il reste seulement un pion
à son adversaire mais le roi est adroit
le roi est à deux cases de deux cases de
ce pion donc il n'a pas le temps d'aller
d'aller le chercher parce qu'évidemment
6 juin coup son adversaire va s'entendre
qui perle qui a perdu autant et donc qui
l'a fait roi prend pions en un seul coup
il a joué deux coups de suite avec son
roi et a tenté comme ça de d'annuler la
page d'inscription adverse en étant
tombée quoi déjà vu quelqu'un tentait de
faire ça alors dans cette position est
ce que maxime ne peut pas simplement
profiter de ce pion 17 qui n'est plus
protégé après le départ du fou manger le
cavalier y re manche est allé simplement
pas reprendre le pion desserte tout à
fait logique alors là la bonne nouvelle
pour les blancs c'est le flou f4 qui
empêche par exemple tourbe et 8 suivi
par tour prend b2 alors est-ce que si on
assiste de toute façon mais évidemment
le fou contrôler la case b8 alors est ce
que les noirs peuvent faire le 5 mai aux
5,5 ou positionnement très très laid
parce qu'après coup j'ai trois regarder
le fou et 6 qui s'est complètement
enfermé et tandis que le fou c4 qui
tapait sur une muraille dans aussi c'est
maintenant ouvert et on voit toujours
pas comment les noirs vont récupérer
leurs pions puisque sur tourbe et 8
on va prendre
a6 et on va rester qu'un pion plus c'est
une position assez écrasante on va voir
ce que la cades murat à jouer parce que
j'imagine qu'il a annoncé la ve fou 17
et c'est maxime qui qui réfléchit voir
un joueur du niveau de la caméra donner
un pion comme ça on se doute bien que
quelque chose il faut aller le vendre
seul pion bosse aussi les normes tant
que je faisais 6 / a pas vraiment pas
grand chose d'affligeant north assez
confortable puisque la dame ne se
retrouvera pas très bien placé en f3 et
il faut aller il faut ce qu'il faut
aller chercher ce pion et voir ce qui se
passe de toute façon on risque pas grand
chose un au pire des cas les noirs
égaliseront dams et 8 ne risque pas
grand chose dams et 8 avec l'idée en cas
d'échangé d'amour reprendrait de la tour
f et un attaque très le fou c4 et le
pion b2i les blancs ne pourrait pas
jouer
enfin il pourrait jouer b3 mais hors fo
prend tour à 1 ce qui donnerait un
avantage matériel au noir donc floue
d'un de ses huit paraître plutôt être un
bon coup est ce que les blancs peuvent
simplement reculer l'heure d'am dam des
trois par exemple mais là on voit
vraiment bien l'utilité de ce fou dont
tu parlais qui contrôle la case b8
absolument là le fou jean la roma jaune
un rôle majeur
et justement au cas de saint-cloud g3
toujours le problème maintenant c'est
que après tour b 8
on peut plus prendre le pion à 6 mais
d'un autre côté les normes peuvent
surprendre le pion b2 non plus on va
reculer en a deux par exemple et le faux
f6 ne peuvent plus prendre le pion b2
donc un choix un choix cornélien au lait
noir est ce qu'ils veulent jouer tour b
8 est enfermé leur fou en 6 ou son tour
b 8 a priori dirait qu'il va faire son
tour b8 coûté en tout cas jusque là
c'est lappartient ok on a repris puis on
s'est bien mal à on va peut-être faire
un tour des réseaux de chic et on attend
de voir comment à mon avis et dams et 8
va être jouée d'un b 3
d'être joué ouais parce que tu attendes
juste une seconde de voir s'il dame b3
et jouer puisque ça devrait arriver pour
être bien sûr d'avoir la position à
moins qu'ils hésitent avec dan des 4 mai
d'un mp3 a l'air très très très logique
west ham des dames des 3 c à ces coupes
tu as envie de jouer quand même fin
d'année car je sais pas il ya quelque
chose qui qui donne pas envie et si
visuellement c'est pas beau maxime qui
s'étire en tout cas bon bah on va
peut-être tournée du coup ci c'est à
dire c'est qu'ils vont encore un peu
réfléchir alors les autres et fille qui
avait coûté à levon aronian justement
dont on a longuement parlé pendant la
pause qui joue tableau réalisé une toute
petite chose si tu veux revenir à la
partie précédente
ouais il dit moi sur dame chez 8 sur la
b3 ya quand même fou prend b2 alors
pourquoi ça marche pas fou pente b2
alors atteint vieille dame p3 justement
vous prend que deux pions tout
simplement et sur dame tombée dedans le
français 4 c'est vrai que ça nous a
échappé moi ça m'a complètement échappé
bon mais c'est quand même les blancs qui
sont les premiers à se mettre sur les
colonnes avec qui des fous prend 1,4
alors c'est joli foot parce que je vous
prends à quatre situées autour des 4 il
ya dame b 3 ça j'avais pas vu tu vois on
a l'impression qu'on va gagner le fou
mais ils contre attaquent la dame est en
fait peut-être que alors sûr que vous
prend 1,4 à peut-être fou prend 1,6
merlin mais dans la variante [ __ ] très
compliqué vous prend 1 h 6 et les normes
ne peuvent pas reprendre hachey sans
menace matane ranger c'est la tour des 4
et maintenant si les blancs les noirs
font dame b3 ou dame ces deux ans on
fera tout rejet quatre échecs suivi par
dame g7 maths ça c'est assez joli comme
variante mais c'est dans le c'est du
calibre d'un maxime vachier lagrave un
trouvé ça il a dû le voir à mon avis
quand il s'est étiré il a dû voir ça
c'est possible ou alors sur fo prend b2
il prévoit autre chose c'est une autre
possibilité alors nous on vous dit ainsi
on voit tous ces variantes ne croyez pas
que c'est parce qu'on est très fort on
est un petit peu aussi l'ordinateur qui
peut aider
donc on peut on peut les voir plus vite
parfois romain j'imagine qu'ils les
voient sans l'aide de l'ordinateur aussi
parfois reçoit souvent à chis non non je
les ai vus j'ai vu apparaître
donc ça normalement romain lui voir
souvent sera paraître mais bon on garde
aussi voilà pour être complètement
transparent avec vous on garde un petit
peu un petit oeil sur l'ordinateur pour
pas raconté trop n'importe quoi alors
ouais non mais écoute fou prend b2 il a
forcément calculé quelque chose maxime
en tout cas regardez les concentrés
comme toujours ça c'est vraiment
impressionnant je n'arrête pas de le
souligner mais tu vois ce n'est pas à
lui de jouer
il a déjà une partie d'une heure dans
les pattes mais il est quand même à fond
c'est très très bien c'est très très
bien bon c'est notre petit tour du cou
oui absolument
alors les jeunes qui jouent tout m pour
il a vraiment décidé de tout jouer
rapidement dans ce tournoi il a de
nouveau un avantage autant conséquent et
une position dans laquelle il a sacrifié
un pion mais il a quelques compensations
voilà avec la paire de fou le le leaf ou
le fou très bien installé un dessin
qu'en cas d' échange des dames ensuite
mettons que les blancs échange les dames
ici avec leurs pions d'avancé jukka et
c3 pour chasser le fou de la case des
cinq les noirs en vain le choix entre
protéger avec ali hafsi sous alors je
vais [ __ ] en f3 pour à fait bien la
structure logistique par exemple mettre
une tour au centre tour f 2,8 et voilà
les normes ont joué par exemple
cavaliers ap 6 3 et 8 retirer leurs fous
quelque part et à les blancs ont une
structure de pointe non plus une
structure de pions affaibli en général
n'est noir arrive à faire mieux ce genre
de position et c'est probablement ce qui
va arriver puisqu'il change des dames et
le cavalier qui est parti en c3 alors
que maxime enlève sa veste en lin les
choses sérieuses vont bientôt commencer
face à l'américain voilà ça se passe
quand même très bien avec les noirs pour
les vins
donc bon choix de kasparov de laisser
lebron titulaire absolue à lanvin aniche
comment il s'en sort contre wesley août
il a l'air d'avoir une bonne position
aussi avec une tour bien installé en d6
oui mais un nigiri est ouest et ceux qui
sont peut-être les deux joueurs les
mieux préparés du circuit un enjeu
je me ferai quand wesley so largement
largement derrière année je guéris par
contre parmi les plus solides du circuit
oui les plus solides les bons m'avantage
pour anis dans cette position avec la
tour en d6 et il nous reste donc nana
zag nisé alors attends c'est toujours
cette histoire va le pseudo c'est sur
l'histoire du pseudo qui s'affiche pas
alors on avait en plus celui tout à
l'heure tu rends c'est fait on s'est
fait on s'est fait doubler on s'est fait
doubler par les pseudo on les a tous ce
qu en réalité a demandé à toutes les
parties qui s'ouvrent les chinois aussi
oui fans avec tout cela est un devoir ou
if un analyste les chinois ont vraiment
une équipe redoutable alors attends je
vais avoir une difficulté pour trouver
si quelqu'un pouvait me l'écrire dans le
chat le pseudo de dan a glissé je
l'avais hier en plus et puis tu vois
c'est comme les parties sont pas
ouvertes au on va retourner sur maxime
pour le moment et on va on va retrouver
ça oui c'est dommage que c'est dommage
que dans là que les parties soient pas
cassé par match oui oui mais là en fait
j'ai l'impression j'ai eu un problème
sur une partie hier mais c'était un
autre match qui s'affichait pas dans les
partis top puisque normalement il
devrait y être on va nous on va nous
donner on va nous donner ça de toute
façon on a beaucoup de choses à regarder
encore et notamment cette partie de
maxime est fou prend b2 a pas eu lieu et
il a joué tour à 7 me soit 7 c'est pas
vraiment une solution à mon avis maxime
qui a l'air d'être content à la caméra
il s'étire ça ne devrait pas être une
solution to race est ici on peut mettre
une tour en c1
ouais a évidemment attendre un petit peu
les pièces maxime qui se concentrent qui
réfléchit et qui est en train de
chercher l'âme aux meilleures options
dois-tu pensez peut-être à tour à ses
seins qui protège le fouet qui se dit en
phase de la dame à la question c'est
est-ce que des noirs peuvent jouer tour
baisse est plus floue prendre les deux
dames des toits il faut prendre des deux
qui tuerait possibilités de découvertes
posture et du foot français gagnent la
tour mais c'est hélas si on joue
simplement tous ces deux ils raflent
points à 4 donc si on joue tourbe est un
pur mais là c'est fou points à 6 tours
bechis elle coule c'est pareil avec les
roms c'est pas loin de tourbe et si seul
coup nous dit l'ordinateur c'est pas
joli joli et sur 1,5 à tour ses six
attaques le fouet le fou c4 mais vont
tomber de touristes étaient des tourbes
et 8 dans tyrode apparemment dame sait
si ce lundi s'en fiche pour b6 m'avait
vu ça après mes lordi fedama 4 et il
tient tout tout reprend 1,6 ou b 5 kg
gants sacs ramassés çà c'est typiquement
les variantes d'ordinateur alors on me
dit que le pseudo alors c'est pas c'est
pas de nanas se serait lilly and i alors
attends on va on va aller chercher sa
vie a dit voilà c'est ça merci un jouet
super comme ça on va voir sa partie
merci pour pour le bon boulot ou une
position intéressante si chilienne à la
pine
alors elle a les noirs anna et elle a
réussi à installer une dame en d3 qui
est une sacrée épine dans le jeu blanc
parce que regarder pousser un et on peut
pas bouger le pion b2 puisqu'il est
obstruée par le pion détroit et on peut
pas bouger le pion d
qui oserait par l'adam ce qui veut dire
que si on bouge la tour et qui a
admettons un échange de dames les noirs
ici les blancs ici ont un sacré problème
pour sortir leurs fous par les jets de
faire cavalier inde et rodez 3 des
choses comme ça mais évidemment c'est un
petit peu c'est un petit peu passif a
passé le cavaliere qui va se retrouve
être obligé de défendre son client
détroit c'est effectivement une grosse
réussite pour les noirs cette ouverture
les bleus viennent de jouer dame ces
deux cas mans c'est vraiment c'est un
échec pour les blancs s'ils sont obligés
d'échanger des dames dans cette position
un développement pour le moment ce début
de match et quand même plutôt en faveur
des européens parce que si on résume on
a un maxime vachier lagrave au premier
échiquier qui a un avantage est qu'il ya
une position qui n'a aucun n'y a aucun
risque
on a les vins aronian o2 qui va un petit
peu souffrir avec un pion de moins mais
quand même on imagine qu'un joueur de ce
calibre-là dans ce genre de final
devrait réussir à prendre le demi point
sans trop de soucis au troisième et chic
et anish giri qui met une petite
pression à wesley so cependant pourquoi
il est changé pour que les dames ont
disparu là parce que je mets bien écoute
parce que c'est les joueurs les plus
solides du circuit fis bon là il n'y a
pas de pression ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre
là le caméléon c5 est revenu un passé
maintenant les normes fairway fuite
recettes sans problème moi j'ai pas du
tout aimé
bon ça donne pas grand chose ici on
imagine plutôt une nulle du coup mais on
a un premier échiquier mv est donc
maxime vachier lagrave avec un avantage
un quatrième échiquier où ça se passe
plutôt pas mal avec les noirs et sur le
reste écoute on a une toute petite
souffrance pour aronian mais on est
quand même devant la roma en ce début de
match ouais ça je pense que je pense me
grosses chances de guingouin aux 4
pas trop de pas trop de difficultés
attention à neiger guérilla pas se
retrouver moins bien quand même parce
qu'il a des pions doublé eux si tu
remets la position d'alger
vas-y j parce que j'estimais est une
force pour les blancs parce qu'il
souvenait la tour des six
et si les bleus arrivent et avec les
dames sur l'échiquier a fait avec 4 5 ap
si ça pouvait être une attaque ou g4 g5
mais sans les dames ce sont les noirs
qui ont la meilleure structure et s'il
arrive à solidifier à échanger par
exemple si les noirs arrivent à le
ramener la roue ans est une tour en des
huit dans la crème des pions double 4,5
faiblesse en a quatre fronts g2 qui est
pas terrible
ouais c'est peut-être dommage de ne pas
faire une ville stratégique où tu fais
rentrer guiry plutôt avec les noirs qui
avec sa préparation et sa solidité peut
prendre des demi point est plutôt faire
jouer dude avec les blancs ce ça aurait
pu être une autre une autre stratégie
intéressante côté européen 2 de plutôt
favorisé les plans pour pour les joueurs
polonais qui est quand même un joueur
plus offensif
voilà après peut-être que kasparov a vu
le scénario venir où on aurait des
bonnes positions avec les blancs au
premier échiquier et avec au dernier est
chic et où on a un jeu un petit peu plus
forte que que la haine et du coup il
cite il a préféré faire jouer année j
eric et plus solides plutôt qu'un no
doubt où tout peut arriver
voilà si la vue sur scénario l'avenir
c'est plutôt bien vu
'cependant maxime vient de rendre le
pion migrants le pion et la cnss c'est
toujours limite un pour les noirs à tour
tous ses atours fc1 ici ouais le fou va
venir en c6 attaqué attaqué j'ai des
deux est finalement peut-être que c'est
quand même c'est pas très joli 1 pour
les noirs quand même même si on doit je
fus f1 est quand même petit très chiant
j'ai l'impression mais bon non il ya une
petite pression encore mais il ya plus
de pions de plus
ap le pion de plus il aurait pu le
rendre peut-être dans des circonstances
encore meilleur il faut un f6 on va voir
comment ça ça continue on va voir
comment ça continue et bons tours fc 1
va être joueur j'imagine donc
l'ordinateur pour vous aussi un coup
élégant fouquet 8 mais est ce que ça
marche super 8 la tour par an à 8 10 6
après seuil et tu vois de retour des 8es
maintenant faire tourner avoir pris la
casse pot à dahouët il aime pas trop
finalement mais ça peut être une ça peut
être quelque chose que regardent
maximale ratant il a joué romain on va
on va tout de suite allé voir le coup
jour en direct
il a joué tout rester un le tout plus de
chic un finalement ni d'hommes à 800
doute être jouée est bon les noirs ont
essayé de jouer tour c8 ou c6 des
changes un maximum de pièces
mais voilà cette faiblesse reste entend
ainsi peut-être qu'on va jouer à cinq
avec les blancs ouais fixé gagner
peut-être la tour ou à la casse des 6 un
jour et continue à mettre la pression et
je prendrai les blancs tous les jours y
siens mais après ce que ça va suffire
c'est la question
c'est la question en vain absolument
marqueurs noah chi chi et qui joue que
saint lô gambie dame etc habitués à
cette position où ils souffrent un petit
peu mais finit par raccrocher la mule
bailly fort instinct caméra vraiment
alors peut-être ici te dame stacy social
pour attaquer le plan à 4 mais surtout
b5
alors faut 25 effectivement donc avec
une double attaque de la dame par la
tour et par le fou simplement bouger la
dame dans le iv par exemple ou même en a
huit ce serait même une amélioration en
force wall e
quand même changé un échange de pièces
favorisera les noirs réussi de noir qui
soufflerait et noir qui manque un peu d
espaces non plus de foot case l'enjeu
est important pour garder la pression
sur le pion à 6
alors on va voir ce qu'il a décidé sur
tours fc 1 il a joué damas est vite et
donc pas d'âme ses six dames a évité à 5
de maxime donc qui suit qui suit ce
conseil de fixer la faiblesse en aura 6
et peut-être de lui mettre la pression
avec du tour b6 à venir aux mains quand
même toujours petit avantage pour le
joueur français dans ce match petit
avantage pour les blancs mais ça va peut
être se voit pas de façon pour les noirs
de vraiment résoudre complètement les
problèmes va falloir être patient mais
voilà nakamura il sait faire ça en
général il a fait tour c'est 8
alors est ce qu'on y skie si on peut
faire simplement à le problème c'est que
si on joue faux f1 il va y avoir foule
univers tout reprend c'est un époux b5
je pense c'est un petit peu embêtant
c'est davantage de garder la tour en
berne c'est que pouvaient 5 n'était
jamais possible que si jamais on prend
prend et qu'on était fou ans et 7 est ce
que j'ai peur que le pion b en fait soit
dangereux lui aussi déjà dams et 8 il
faut garder ça veut dire que le fou va
commencer à être attaqués que le pion
bva pouvoir filer jusqu'en b2 soutenu
par as
j'ai peur que ce puisse mal se passer ça
donc c'est ce qui arrive aux arnaques à
murat fouet fin jouer il va sûrement y
avoir pour français français s'est jouée
et fourbe et cinq exactement romain bien
vu ouais ouais bah cinéma arrive à
l'équidé autant de pièces
il n'aura pu davantage pour les blancs
ok donc comme aura qu'à un peu choix mon
avis tu avais son tour à cet avis était
pas tout tous n'étaient pas sous
contrôle et maxime l'agent a inspiré un
peu relax avec avec soin coup de damas
deux et ça a suffi
ce petit coup ce petit coup de moins
moins offensif on avait agressifs que
les autres a suffi pour pour permettre
aux joueurs américains de se remettre
alors que la maxime du tour bain avec un
petit piège sur foot.fr et peut-être
tourbe et éviter shaker mon petit piège
gros piège même et évidemment on a comme
moi ne veut pas se laisser faire sous
des huit souhaitent liquider
alors là ça peut continuer par vous
prouver c'est un client prend b5 tout
reprend vc1 et menaces tourbe et huit
tours prend 1,5 menace la dame est à
tourtour prend à 52.5 dame prend à 5
francs à cinq c'est vraiment la position
qu'on pourra avoir sur l'échiquier d'ici
quelques quelques minutes et ça ce
serait new leurs avoirs à moins que
maxime trouve une petite idée pour
essayer de jouer pour le gain mais fou
des huit problème c'est que le fou en
baisse 5 maintenant est trop bien placé
alors est ce que parce que je peux te
faire [ __ ] 5,9 voilà ça va faire nul
on va aller s'il va rester sur cette
partie quelques secondes le temps de les
voir signer là nul je pense pas que ça
joue très longtemps romain semblablement
ils doivent pas avoir trop posé nue les
noms suivent ont simplement répété
anaruz marché il m fait donc un petit
peu décevante parce que ça paraissait
séparés c'est un peu limite pour les
noirs donc espérons donc à rené auque
lit on à l'office des complies qu'il
quitte bientôt mieux compensation et
coûte aronian qui rogne ans qui m'étonne
qui m'étonne vraiment c
c'est incroyable de le voir réussir
quand même à se remobiliser à bien jouer
à se remettre bien devant un échiquier
c'est extraordinaire vraiment ça fait
très plaisir alors sur 1,4 ici que ce
qu'il veut faire ce qu'il faut éviter à
4 des noirs sinon le plein de cadeaux va
être perdus sur 1,4 et ce qu'il veut
faire
qu'est ce qu'il va faire sur quatre qui
est en jeu
excuse moi s'est pas très bien passé
pour pour mon côté technique je vais m
kirin petites secondes je réglerai ça
après vous utilisez sur à 4 donc c'est
le l'idée c'est empêcher à 4 1 pour
conserver gelac d mais c'est vrai que
des nains peuvent eux simplement pour
les compensations g55 avale un f4 et en
fait les blancs ce sont les noirs qu'ils
ont joué pour gagner ici avec aussi fort
à tout moment cavalli aussi c'est pour
récupérer le plomb des quatre f5 ce
train avec l'appui d'un ranger cette
pièce ou plus apsys future a45 serait
certainement jouer s entendent pas
davantage la renault il a joué à quatre
est d'ailleurs celle qui a été jouée
mais pour éviter que les noirs le jouer
à quatre pour éliminer le défenseur du
pion des quatre ans que sinon il ya eu à
quatre cavaliers bouger cavaliers des 5
et 6 et le plan des quatre est tombé sur
un coup droit g16 des blancs et
simplement sa suivi attaques de la tour
suivi partout au point des quatre et les
bleus noirs ont une meilleure structure
de pions ou qu à la place ils décident
d'éviter ça et jouent à 4 et g5 a été
joué évidemment des cinq énormes
installe un cavalier en f4 et là c'est
le pense très confortable pour les noirs
alors là il est noir qui sont les noirs
qui sont bien alors
à lui je guéris qui a joué fouet faim
très faim voilà moi j'ai un peu peur que
les noirs arrivent à jouer
bref hui trois sets tour des huit tours
d'essai en fait le rêve des noirs se
seraient malades arrivent et je leur ai
fui 3,7 tour des huit alors peut-être
pas tout reprend des six parce que ça
laisserait plus on prendrait six échecs
mais ensuite tour 17 et retour des 8es
et changer les quatre tours ce serait la
catastrophe pour les blancs avec cette
structure de pions j'ai un tout petit
peu peur je pense que les blancs d'oeufs
doivent avoir assez de jeu ici pour ses
frères tour ces quatre cavaliers à tour
c'est cathy fra b si c'est ça que tu
veux tout a dû peut-être parfois du
veegaete
ou juste f4 et un aileron trois
peut-être que c'est je pense pas que les
blancs soient soient moins bien des noms
un plan clair en tout cas il est bonne
aussi dair ce que je voulais rajouter
c'est qu'il reste plus que cinq minutes
un pur domingues 2 min 35 avions
baronian continuer dans ces schémas
comme ça qui quand il est lancé chez mme
haïder roulant il peut terminer des
partis avec plus de temps avec plus de
temps que le temps qui lui est imparti
au début qui en a payé un agrément 10
secondes par coup des fois ça peut
arriver que qu'à la fin de la partie les
plus de temps qu'au début mais ça se
passe au cias et bien sûr le 4ème
échiquier alors les blonds un peu
amélioré leur structure des pions mais
en ayant mené leur coeur et dans ses
quatre parce que les noirs étaient
obligés de laisser faire ça pas facile
est arrivés après on était pas obligé de
prendre ça paraît logique de quand même
pas se laisser mourir
bon mais il ya un avantage à la pendule
aussi j'ai l'impression que quand même
le match tourne assez bien le match
oppose pas mal mais il va falloir mettre
un point quelque part est ce que tu veux
qu'on se concentre sur aniche sur
peut-être sur les bornes c'est la partie
qui va bouger le
le plus vite à mon avis c'est la partie
qui va qui va arriver plus vite parce
que parce que les joueurs sont mal aux
fins le joueur blanc emma l'otan et donc
les vonn qui devrait qui devra enchaîner
les coups ici côté noir et dominguez qui
sera bien obligé parce qu'on rappelle
ainsi arrive à zéro au chronomètre
il perd de la partie et c'est pas très
amusant non plus d'arriver à 10 secondes
au chronomètre et devoirs de devoir
jouer sur l'agrément des 10 secondes par
coup parce que 10 secondes pour jouer un
coup aux échecs c'est pas beaucoup
ouais elle a fait tout risque il va y
avoir des cavaliers f4 cavaliers 6 pour
pour aller s'emparer du pion kef quatre
cavaliers aussi sert les blancs vont
mettre la tour en verre et on va essayer
des blancs vont essayer de s'accrocher
quand même pion aux pions devait il peut
réussir à mener peut-être le roi par là
je sais pas si ça peut être un plan
sympa photo mh écoute
c'est optimiste mais si tu y arrives
leroy qui pourrait monter à la volée un
à long terme non mais pourquoi pas moi
j'ai ici soit un coût kovalev quatre ans
à tshikapa
si les noirs se font pas match le roi
peut être pourquoi pas aller jouer roi
h3 est allé chercher le pion aux deux
bref c'est un plan typique danseuse dans
ce genre de finale avec cette structure
mais l'habitude ne le fait plus tôt
quand il ya plus de pièces sur
l'échiquier c'est à dire en finale deux
pions avec nous il ne reste que les rois
et des pions depuis quatre pièces sur
l'échiquier plus s'ils risquent
évidemment d'amener son roi dans des
contrées un peu exotique mais pourquoi
pas alors est ce qui fait roi g6 pour
aller tout de suite en h5 ou est ce
qu'il veut il a simplement d'avoir
préparé le terrain avec 3g 6 il va
d'abord faire kf4 savoir tout ce qui se
passe j'ai l'impression qu'il va jouer
cavalier f4 ici parce que ça attaque
bloquions ce que ça peut être une idée
pour les blancs d'oeufs
de mettre le carélien 9,4 pour compris
la case des six basse et surtout quid
maintenant il va prendre l'option b 6 on
va avoir un ça continue à jouer tempo il
a joué cavalier pkk et b4 qui est malin
puisqu'il empêche toujours ses six
n'empêche tour csu s'est donc il va
falloir c'est probablement kébé 3 de
retour
oui et il pourrait avoir l'idée de
remettre ce cas et maman c'est 6%
prendre option des 4 ou alors maintenant
il va la f4 mais en passant par détroit
a eu des mots sur la tour vient du
romain et à prévenir vers f4 oui il
aurait pu riz peut réaliser ce plan de
manière très très élégante avec aval et
ab4 le retour et du coup il va il va
peut-être faire ça ce qu'on rêve 4 ce
cavalier serait bien faut faut expliquer
pourquoi mais ils bloqueraient ils
bloquent les droits ils contrôleraient
la case dessin qui seraient prêts à
repartir vers 6 une fois en f4 pour
attaquer le pion et kerry détroit très
bien joué et là il continue à mettre la
pression autant je ne pense pas qu'à
royal prennent beaucoup de temps dans
cette partie j'imagine bien finir au
dessus des du quart d'heure est-ce que
ce qu'il est vraiment en mode ce qui est
ce qu'il est simplement en mode zéro
problème je fais nul ou est ce qui va
vraiment aller chercher la victoire
je ne sais pas oui le cavalier f4 qui
est très fort pour la simple raison déjà
qui bloquent deux pions blancs et ne
peut être attaqué par aucun autre pion
blanc s'il ya les blancs n'ont pas de
pions et papillon j'ai donc le cavalier
ici et sur une casse forte et sûre ni
sur une case forte et effectivement il
n'empêche il a dit neil là ils attaquent
la tour blanche qu'il empêche aussi le
roi blanc de sortir il pourrait y avoir
il pourrait y avoir des thèmes de maths
du couloir donc imaginons qu'une la tour
des huit se métamorphosent ici et vienne
jusqu'en h1 par exemple un match du
christ un math du couloir
grâce aux cavaliers qui contrôle les
cases de sortie dure blanc fait retirer
les 6 5 a réussi cela pour forcer tour
des uns est complètement paralysé les
trois pièces blanches à la défense du
pion il préfère cavaliers aux 6 et puis
un moment donné ça serait pas mal qu'il
fasse f6 pour pour qui est plus un
problème de tours ces six échecs et puis
ça va finir par arriver je crois
rush 5 1 une autre opposition deux nuls
je vais essayer de j'ai entendu une
petite alerte de voir sur quel échiquier
ça m'étonnerait pas non c'est pas là
c'est pas là non plus ça devrait être
sur l'échiquier de l'even même si je la
vois pas mais ça a dû être refusées oued
evans qui a refusé la nul donc ça répond
à ta question d'accords refuse à
l'écouté très bien belles équipes
d'europe là qui est en train de réaliser
son meilleur match jusqu'à maintenant
romain c'est le premier match qu'on
maîtrise un petit peu ça pas dit qu'on
le gagne mais c'est le premier match on
est en maîtrise on est devant parce que
jusqu'à maintenant le seul match qu'on a
gagné c'est celui que vous avez suivi
il ya quelques quelques minutes de cela
on a battu l'inde mais ce n'était pas un
match en contre olemps c'est un match
qui sert tourner en notre faveur de
manière inattendue à la fin mais là
c'est un match qu'on contrôle pour le
moment et romain absolument absolument
avec avec l'avantagé avec les pièces
noires bizarrement rien du tout avec les
blancs enfin déjà une le signe avec les
blancs et probablement pas davantage
pour pourra niche mais n'est parti se
passe à merveille avec thé noir est
effectivement 20 minutes contre 2
pourquoi au nom accepterait de faire nul
ici alors est-ce qu'il peut pas essayer
aussi des cavaliers detroit et cavaliers
prend b2 avec sa wii cavaliers detroit
dans ce tour b un chip imagine peut-être
un entourent f4 donc voilà on va déjà
occupé un pion ça va pas ça ouais on
veut peut-être tour h4 alors attends ça
continue à jouer à toute blinde 1 c'est
assez spectaculaire et des trois jouent
à être plein de tours b 1
allez bonne là qui à mon avis qui ne va
jamais prendre le temps il va il va pas
se servir de son temps d'avant s'il va
servir du temps pour au contraire mettre
encore plus la pression sur l'adversaire
est pas le laisser respirer web à la
position tellement facile à jouer mais
d'appeler bon il faut quand même faire
attention à tour ses six échecs ce genre
de choses dr f 4 tours saisissent échec
je sais pas ce
ce qu'on jouera h 56 ou simplement c'est
bizarre ou h5 un mec un cavalier qui
peut venir en g3 plutôt un peut-être
plutôt epci sinon je serais tu aurais vu
de manière plus tranquille mais avant ça
continue à vous la fais tout reste
quatre courses et si justement il a
lille rouen g7 les vols sa playlist
oublie pas du tout donc monté six tours
prend des quatre tours en f1 en d4
probablement autour b points des quatre
tours dépend des cadres d'air d2 en
l'air bien ouais et du coup tu vas tu
entres en option 1 4 puis tu vas
peut-être voir vous allez au hca si tu
gagnes age 2 tu vas me dire un prix la
semaine quelle preuve de oui oui je
reprends tes 4 juin sera même quel point
f the way et dominguez qui a plus qu'une
livre 40
c'est l'impression qui veut gagner moi
notre idée est bonne tout cas ce serait
une grosse une grosse performance de la
part toujours arménien ainsi fini la
journée à 2 sur deux américains qui
pourront regretter de ne pas avoir mis
caruana avec les blancs quand même parce
que même si dominguez un super joueur de
rapides
le problème c'est que il est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup moins bien préparé car
onians alors que alors que caruana et
sans doute par à rognan que ce que tu en
penses caruana ils sont à peu près les
deux sont très bien préparés mais au
jour d'aujourd'hui peut-être que caruana
et même un petit peu de vent
oui quand même quand même bien sûr et
d'ouverture c'est une ouverture ce
contrat un contrat d'heure comme à ronan
après j'étais en train de demander est
ce que est ce qu'il n'ya pas un problème
autre pour caruana parce que ne pas être
titularisé de la journée c'est quand
même très étonnant saric si bizarre
alors que le problème de le problème de
faire jouer un jeu de faire jouer une
ronde sur deux s'était que après c'est
pas forcément facile d'alterner les
couleurs alors peut-être qu'il décide de
en fait peut-être aussi que dit il fonde
et il préfère donner des journées de
repos entière à des joueurs au plus tôt
de foot plutôt que de fatigue et les
joueurs tous les jours ils préfèrent
faire jouer deux parties
ils préfèrent ils préfèrent donner des
journées de repos entier pour que les
joueurs se reposent 100% ouais enfin se
priver de karwan art en tout cas c'est
un choix fort de l'entraîneur qui en
train de ne pas payer un finalement qui
est en train de ne pas payer alors on va
voir comment comment les bonnes la
transforme alors maintenant il peut
faire quelques problèmes de roy preuve
de tout reprendre et 2 est allé
récupérer le pion âge de se retrouver
avec un pion +1 avec les noirs
éventuellement war iii n'était pas
obligatoire mais moi j'ai trois
peut-être mais alors là est ce qu'on va
pas ce qu'on va pas se faire mater avec
du hasch tourache cote
ça sent pas bon romain cat et sion joue
h3 et avoir f5 menace f4 maths mais tu
es obligé 4 soit man avec les blancs
tour france
tout allait alors voir ce qu'il a joué
avec les noirs il a joué cavalier point
f2 à ea et dominguez qui prend pas le
cavalier qui foudroie eux deux ouais
mais bon il ya le tour à venir tellement
foutu mais alors j'ai quarante secondes
contre 20 minutes ça va pas être une
partie de plaisir
revenir en d3 partir vers 1 h 4 tours h4
directes 50 secondes pour dominguez et
on sent que c'est une partie importante
pour le destin du tournoi romain
pour le dessin de cette équipe
européenne absolument
ce sera sans doute l'impression que ça
va être la partie de la victoire du
match - avoir à voir en tout cas plus de
30 secondes
ray dominguez cavaliers f1 a forcé le
cavalier va amener un regard des jeux
directement ragnar ni la 19 minute
encore et il a pris il a pris une 9
secondes pour remettre le cavalier en d3
ça ça me rappelle une
anecdote en équipe de france une partie
que maxime vachier lagrave avait
malheureusement perdu contre à rognan et
maxime avait perdu avec les blancs en
terminant avec deux heures à la pendule
très vite très confiant et son truc
marchait pas et il avait perdu et à
rognan la fin de la partie s'était levé
et nous avait dit mais voyez je sais
pourquoi je vais aussi vite que sage et
2800 quand même qu'il avait dit ça sous
la forme sous la forme d'une blague mais
savait pas trop du l'amusé non plus quoi
il avait il avait pas dire soit qu'il
n'avait pas dit à maxime une fois qu'il
avait dit a qu'une ou peut-être que
c'est à maxime d'heure les deux des deux
de deux s'entendent très bien mais c'est
vrai parce que la position elle n'était
pas génial et continuer de jouer trop
vite
j'ai toujours été pauvres peut-être pour
donner l'illusion de quelque chose qui
marche mais là ce qui fait un rhodia ne
s'est pas mal
il fait un coup il réfléchit après ils
rejouent tempo et il fait des petits
changements de rythme c'est extrêmement
mal hein mais qu'at-il prévu sur 3 à 5 3
le mans tours c3 pour rentrer en c2
alors j'aurais plutôt dit tourache 3 - 1
et pour s'en prendre aux gens au point
en f3 ceci les blancs si les blancs
symbole s'interposait quelques cavaliers
à angers 3 on 3 ailleurs à tour pointent
deux échecs
il a plus que huit secondes dominguez
aller ce qui va tomber et ça peut
arriver un tu sais c'est rare mais dans
des positions aussi difficile à jouer
ouais donc surtout rage 3 il veut avoir
tourtois il pourrait commencer par
cavalier des cinq voies comme ou alors
les preuves de ce qu'il peut pas faire
tourner ses trois ici pour entendre ces
deux menaces qu'elle ait trois
fourchettes
ouais ça sur ses troisièmes à la russie
et sur wii et il masque à détroit et
surtout qu'on a cinq ont refait tout
rage 3 way pour ces trois ça me paraît
être le coup de plus humain oui mais
assez fort allez les bonnes pour ces 3
jouez jouez toujours que qu'une
quinzaine de secondes pour son
adversaire plus que 8 maintenant
ce suspect il pleut il pleut on peut
vraiment tomber dans ce genre de
situation c'était il est vrai qu'une
seconde une seconde donc là en plus il
l'a il a perdu un temps plateau va bien
mieux placés en c3 camp quand des trois
régimes entourage 3 quand même ça va
prendre en f3 déjà il pleut il pleut il
faut se consoler avec un film puissant
l'a immédiatement ah non il peut
préparer et arrêtent un tri proterre
surprotège maintenant des bons tours
mais mon entourage point f3 et la tour
voire en transe et 2 c'est pour ça
qu'elle est bien mieux passé en en d3 -
pouvaient pas rentrer sur la seconde
rangée tout de suite à cause du cavalier
né à tourcoing f3 tour ces deux ce sont
les réseaux nat de partout ça devrait
faire un côté côté arménien
ok il est chaud à la cam 1 il est
bouillant ça se voit il est bouillant de
chez bouillant il calculait ils veulent
finir confiant et on le voit sourire et
ça fait plaisir de le voir sourire jeu
on serait bête on peut mais c'est normal
c'est normal d'être heureux pour ce
procès pour ce garçon cet homme qui a
vécu des choses difficiles et qui est
qui peut retrouver au moins un peu de
plaisir avec les échecs avec un niveau
de jeu qui à mon avis doit doit le
réjouir de revenir comme ça
absolument donc ils happy world j'ai un
morceau fait de la nature l écureuil h3k
relief deux qui peuvent rodez les cavs a
lieu deux échecs les tours j'ai deux
échecs là il y en a il y en a une
ribambelle alors j'ai l'impression que
il va mettre une tout ranger de l'autre
en f2 puis cabaye âge 3 et puis choisis
ton poison dit on cause on s'arrête là
le réseau tour j'ai droit à chatou rêve
de carélie h3 et ahmad imparable angers
un tour b6 ne servent absolument à rien
il sait pas quoi jouer le pauvre
dominguez s'est complètement foutu il
peut le faire ou alors il peut la jouer
simple avec cavale et h3 échec 3 h un
tour ff2 et le prochain coup c'est tout
rejet de manas m'attend j'ai un des six
cavaliers bouge
matt en h2 alors il réfléchit se prend
la tête mais à mon avis c'est juste
qu'il voit plein de bonnes solutions là
et sait plus comment gagner et c'est
plus quelqu'un choisir ouais là il y en
a plein on le voit il est en avançant
qu'il est sur des ressorts la y est quoi
oui sorti un petit peu ouais c'est bon
si ça continue au tir et bon choix de
garry kasparov en tout cas parce que tu
vois ça c'est un choix qu'on n'aurait
pas à pas forcément fait de le relancer
les votes dans ce tournoi il a dû lui
parler et et run là qui fait très très
mal
aujourd'hui c'est lui qui pourrait être
l'instigateur des deux victoires
européennes absolument absolument avec
alors mais surtout cette victoire contre
c'est pas encore signé mais cette partie
contre dominguez
ça faisait très longtemps que j'avais
pas vu dominguez perdre une partie comme
ça avec les blancs se faire même même si
c'est du rapide 1 dominguez qu'un joueur
quand même très solide très très propre
à se faire massacrer comme ça avec les
pièces blanches et les marquages 3 et
abandon alors là on me reste tour g1
matin pour bien expliquer sur cavalli ou
trois pour protéger la casse g1 ils y
auraient tous reproches de ses mates
imparable il va y avoir avant donc sûr
que maillage 3 voilà est extraordinaire
il petit sourire un qui fait plaisir de
lemon une master class 1 de la part de
vannes et il part tout heureux ça y est
parti et comptant belles belles parties
vraiment bravo à lui et il nous est
vraiment sur de très très bons rails
wesley so on va peut-être pas
s'éterniser parce que kiri cette finale
elle est nulle théorique et il n'y a
aucun risque à mon avis il sait faire
guérigny il perdra pas cette finale deux
tours mais des mets alors mais alors les
noirs avaient commandé un tout petit
avantage quand même ouais disons qu'ils
ont conservées jusque là mais qui ne
suffira pas et du coup tout va se jouer
finalement sur
sur mana mais on a ici un net avantage
aussi avec un gros pions de plus ça sent
la victoire après ce serait ce serait la
bonne surprise ce serait la bonne
surprise du jour
romain l'asse 2 victoires 2 victoires
effectivement on en parlait comme d'un
scénario qui pouvait lui arriver à un
moment donné pendant ce match contre
l'inde qui était si difficile et
finalement finalement on est bien parti
est plutôt bien parti c'est pratiquement
fait j'ai envie de bien et il nous
resterait plus il nous restera en plus
la seule équipe qu'on n'a pas joué
serait l'équipe supposée la plus faible
donc l'équipe du reste du monde et ça
pourrait complètement quatre victoires
dans la première ronde de demain on
pourrait on pourrait être deuxièmes
derrière la chine 1 absolument
absolument ça on a donc là on est
complètement relancé et voilà dans les
matchs retour il va falloir il va
falloir cartonné dans les matchs retour
maintenant
ouais mais tout va se jouer à pas grand
chose
en tout cas tu nous porte vers la chine
qui a encore un train de gagner en tout
cas c'est une bonne nouvelle un qui
prend le large alors une bonne nouvelle
oui et non ça dépend si on veut se
contenter de la médaille d'argent ou pas
alors tu as une grande finale à la fin
entre le 1er et 2e ah bon alors c'est
vrai j'avais oublié alors écoute que les
nos amis des chinois face parce le
ménage et voilà le on se contentera de
la deuxième place est par contre en
finale on a vous réponds plus de rien
non au final on ne répond plus de rien
mais laissons les prendre le prendre le
la et sont les pâtes tout le monde
écoute y seront trop beau avant la
finale et on en profitera pour pour les
prendre en contre si lens est dans cette
partie pour organiser qu'un plan de plus
pas facile a pas facile à concrétiser
mais évidemment une position qui ne peut
jamais être perdu en principe sont que
peut-être un petit coup d'oeil ce
caniche et ce caniche s'en sort avec 10
minutes chacun à la pendule ça devrais
je vous rallye je perds ça je vous redis
ce faire ça j'ai envie de dire je ne
sais pas ce qui se passe a laissé
pratiquement toutes les finales deux
tours avec trois pions contre deux sur
la même elles sont nulles pratiquement
tout est là c'est pas une exception à
cette règle
voilà les noirs peuvent passer l'avant
avec 5 le toit suite ça ça doit être
assez simple
alors 4 il va y avoir j'imagine roi g2
pour à deux tours et 8 non il tour à
deux tours à deux on peut prendre h5
surprend h5 il y aura peut-être ici 3
ouais bon ou encore tours age 2 3 et tu
peux peut-être faire faire juste aurait
eu aussi un peu n'importe quand et
n'importe quoi autant prendre le pion à
mon avis parce que peu trois quarts wave
3 je vois pas dans quel monde à nice
perd sa non tourache huit tours à 5
l'idée c'est de tourner un petit peu en
rond avec les noirs ils obligés aussi
pour le match alors est ce que est ce
qu'on va essayer d'aller chercher le
camp aux quatre pour le goal avérage
pense que de toute façon tant claude
partie n'est pas finie il faut pas se
poser de questions faut jouer pour le
gain parce que tu peux pas vraiment
faire nul tout de suite
non ça c'est sûr et on avait quatre
minutes contre une normalement à devra
gagner 7 7 partis qui vont l'amener au
garage 5g quatre cavaliers cinq fins oui
je pense que je pense que ça va faire 3
1 ce match sans trop de soucis c'est un
match qui est vraiment à l'image à
l'image tu sais de notre match hier
contre
contre les chinois un match qui s'est
très mal passé pour nous on a été dominé
de a à z surtout les échiquiers en étant
rapidement complètement foutu et là
c'est le même scénario qui se répète
notre faveur un match on n'a pas eu
l'impression à un seul moment de suez
n'ont absolument ça sentait même serait
même pu être un score presque pu être un
score plus gros parce que j'avais
l'impression qu'on était mieux avec les
blancs mais coûte 3 contre les états
unis c'est déjà une sacrée performance
est né pauvre fille qui va peut-être
commencer à regretter
le point de goal avérage qu'il a donné
aussi parce que les russes soient un peu
loin nous on va être devant c'est passé
à des équipes qui ont un peu risqué leur
goal avérage hier c'était c'était
nepomniachi qui a pris trop de risques
et je pense que vu à quel point le
tournant est serré ça sert à rien de
laisser des points de goal avérage en
cours de route 1 effectivement la
deuxième place les chinois ont l'air
bien parti pour pour la première phase
mais pour la deuxième ça va ça va se
jouer à pas grand-chose point to point
de goal avérage est bon à prendre
nachi qui s'est rattrapé quand même pour
sa 2 pour sa défaite d'hier
il vient de battre radjabov donc
l'équipe de russie en train de battre le
reste du monde à figure toi que tu n'as
pas ce que je vois les blancs sont bio
partout donc on viendra dessus tout à
l'heure mais j'ai l'impression que fit
road à l'amphi rhodia contre contre
artemiev ce sera toi certainement nul
car yakine avec les blancs avec l'
avantage contre corrie donc ça va ça va
aller pour et music uk music show qui
est par contre beaucoup mieux contre guy
ria musique zouk qui joue pour le reste
du monde l'autre co music shop pas la
nôtre la moins forte
alors la moins forte qu'il ya quand même
été champion de championne du monde il
ya deux ans ou trois ans oui mais censé
être moins forte assure n'aura sur nos
neveux dieter parle surtout de fortes
mais bon on va essayer de se rassurer
avec ce qu'on peut
moi y est trois minutes pour nana est à
33 secondes pour anna est ce assez
marrant fait les prénoms derna contrat
n'a pas fait gaffe non ça c'est amusant
alors est ce qui va y avoir tellement de
bondoukou qui donne envie à pour pour
les noirs il faut faire un choix c'est
jamais facile hein quand est gagnant
comme ça en finale
tellement facile de se tromper 5h05 tout
de suite soit d'avoir un petit achat qu
on ne sait pas de quel tour tour 8 me
paraît plus naturel tour 8,3 des deux
cavaliers aux cinq cavaliers bien changé
je pense à moi tu es blanc prennent en
h4
moi j'aimerais moi je vois un truc comme
ça je viens demander si c'était vraiment
gagnant pour les noirs ou pas ça
vraiment bien et puis on des pions sont
dangereux ça c'est sûr c'est un peu
notre jeu en passant la torah sur la
colonne h
mais bon on va voir ce que décide à la
fée tour et sa 3d 2,5 manière très
naturelle
oui il fait un truc je vois que
l'ordinateur propose un coup alors c'est
pas forcément ça en fait qu'à aller aux
cinq apparemment et l'homme est meilleur
mais il propose un coup qu'est ce qui
m'amuse ch 3 pour pour que les blancs
prennent de la tourache en h3 et après
cavaliers aux cinq as joué la finale
deux tours sans que les blancs les la
possibilité de ramener l'eau tour sur la
colonne âge bon c'est un peu bizarre jeu
bizarre que de passer pour perdre un
temps pour pour le faire quoi ouais non
c'était cepal c'est pas le mieux aux
pieds noirs est amené à faire mais j'ai
vu ça les premières propositions j'ai
trouvé ça étrange où kyle 5
c'est très bien et si un choix pour les
blancs qui prend le 5e est proche 4 mai
qu'elle prend le 5 avec un nécessaire
après la raison de jouer thème pour un
atteinte ce qui re pour remonter un peu
autant mettre la pression parce que si
au delà d'être mal en plus il ne reste
plus que cinq secondes comme dominguez
tout à l'heure ça ira de mal en pire
après 1 je pense qu'il faut j'ai eu
quatre ici à l'anc et blanc et le temps
de f3 quand même j'étais en train de me
dire que dans tous les cas même
admettons qu on arrive comme ça il n'y
aura pas de perte est non parce que je
peux me cachais grâce au nantes aura pas
de ra pas de perp est alors les blancs
ça ma vie sera obligé sur sur des trois
échecs ou et trois échecs tafer prise
prise admettons la rose de plus tôt
ouais deux maintenant way a maintenant
alors que la différence après eux deux
je suis patient en fait peut-être 3 f 3
ar wech 3 et sur le 2 on aura
internationale tuez la loi pas ce que le
roi n'aurait plus la case f4 pour se
cacher c'est surtout croisé 5e retour h
cinq matches m donc on est obligé de
repartir vers le haut et ça va pas
gagner donc à la fée touré fuite avec
les noirs à la page web pour usage de
tous réfutent heures attention il n'y a
plus trop de temps
j'aime pas trop ça mais d'un autre côté
à gries a fait nul nul nul signé chez
gurit donc une nul nous suffit
officiellement maintenant romain pour
aller chercher le point
tous avaient fui 3e 2 kubisa a donc elle
ne veut pas jouer
3 parce qu'elle veut garder cette
possibilité de tours h3 ne m'en peuvent
insister un jeu autour ef 7 il va
vraiment forcer f3 ou alors il peut
encore ils peuvent encore le cas très
poussée elle peut craquer alors là tu
conseilles quand même là le match le
match et gagner en cas de nul et ce que
tu proposes nul tu prends le match et
tant pis tant pis pour le demi point
est-ce que tu t'en tu la gagnes tu te
comportes comme entourant l'équipe dans
ces situations là
avec 40 secondes à la pendule
bon on va dire que là la position est
tellement passé tellement sous contrôle
ici pour les noirs quand même toujours
partisan des de prendre là nul mais bon
je sais pas peut-être trop mauvaise
expérience
well as et peut-être surtout rage cinq
échecs elle va avoir le choix soit soit
fairway f4 pour jouer la gagne soit on
n'annule accroîtront g4 avec quelques
secondes à la pendule ça paraît pas
illogique de faire nul voilà après un
regard différent g4 entourage parce qu'à
la fin de chaque nom d'accord avec
quelques secondes à la pendue mais bon
roi f4 le roi est tellement bien protégé
des trois échecs tours à huit qui arrive
genre c'est tellement ça a l'air
tellement sans risque pour les noirs que
prix tatoulu missclick le attention
tourache catéchèse suivi par g6 mais bon
les choses des choses que donc à arriver
oui c'est vrai qu'à l'hommiste clics sur
internet
on a probablement atteint probablement
raison j'aurais plutôt je pense que
j'aurais plutôt tendance aussi à faire
nul sauf si vraiment je sens que que je
suis en contrôle
parce que finalement 3 1 ou 2 ennemis
c'est pas que c'est pas négligeable pour
l'équipe non plus n'y a pas tellement de
matches que ça qu'ils vont se gagner
parfois c'est vrai aussi
et donc voilà pour le savez à la fin ça
peut faire une place en finale
tout simplement après le peut aussi
l'âge ou la psychologie juarez trois
jours h 3o f4 fait dire à son adversaire
à troyes prendre la responsabilité de la
répétition et de la défaite c'est ça mon
avis c'est ce qui va être joué et ça va
faire nul à mon avis parce que je vois
pas trop comment les blancs touré faire
autrement tourache kata réfléchit à
faire bref cinq peut-être a donc ajoute
bien tu vois avec les noirs gsi soit
projet 6 mai mais bon elle a deux points
d'avance absolument aucun thème de
matisse il faut qu'elle fasse 3g 5 et
qu'elle a quatre à six voies sont
maintenant je reviens à angers 6 tu
t'attaques la tourelle ne peut pas faire
tout reprendre le 4 et tu fais nul tu
vas pas tomber t'a fait roi russie s'est
joué cette finale pendant des heures aux
epci si tu veux jouer
d'ailleurs il a fait 3,6 aille
maintenant y avoir des cinq camps mais
l'autre a pas pris c'est que ce coup oui
c'est tromper là accessoires livrés
avait fait au moins 4 mai - y avait il y
avait tellement qu'un risque pour les
nord s'étai c'est illogique de jouer
alors pas faire tampon entre point qu'à
toi est là elle a craqué avec les blancs
écoute elle a craqué avec les blancs
elle a laissé puisque l'idée un cd que
le roi s'éloigner de la tour c'est que
les normes les plans pouvait prendre le
pion et après croquer le pion détroit et
ça faisait nul direct mais en ne
mangeant pas en ne mangeant pas le pion
bas elle a laissé les noirs venir
revenir vers le 5 est maintenant sur
échec à tours f5 annoncé complètement
perdus où il ya même où il ya même trois
des quatre ont vaillamment droit des
quatre encore plus fort est roi c'est
troyes et tours matri 3 c'est au tour à
un matt cain gaffe tout âge 6 échecs
enfin des 400 plus fort alors qu'elle
avait trouvé un bon elle trouve un joli
petit piège avec ce j'ai six échecs tour
hsl avais je le trouve une jolie nul et
la maintenance et 3 c3
une foule est souverain ça arrive une
minute 8 watts fin va être joué un bon
tour à deux sans doute vous des 2 3 je
crois gagne 2,3 le mieux un choix de 3 c
trois centres et pop3 il y aura trois
l'abandon devrait pas trop traîner elle
veut faire maths comme ça c'est aussi
sympa c'est pas mal non plus sur f3 il
fera ou trois pour maintenir et c'est
gagné que 3 1 3 un superbe match de la
team europe
ouais mais de belles journées 1 grosse
journée côté côté européen
nouvelle victoire alors dans les autres
matches
romain qu'est ce qui se passe et on va
déjà regarder les scores
la russie mène 2-0 maintenant vers iv
avec une victoire de khanaqine je
suppose mais les deux les deux joueurs
avec les blancs de l'équipe du reste du
monde met la pression
je crois je crois que l'autre match est
fini aussi
ouais la chine qui l'emportait et la
chine doit importer deux ennemis un
ennemi alors peut-être priorité au
direct est ce qu'on peut regarder par
exemple la partie de kiruna aller ils
ont à la 15 secondes chacun fit ruzza
qui doit absolument l'emporter pour que
son équipe a encore une chance de match
nul et qui est longue avance ouais et
une position assez sympa à jouer un côté
côté firoud déjà un c'est sympa mais pas
encore gagné mais on nous dit dans le
chat que les russes se réveille et line
époque où la veillée une époque où
pendant plusieurs années les russes ne
gagnais le gagner plus rien il faisait
même plus il faisait même plus de
médailles ou de podium
et puis tout à coup il se met à se
mettre à performer encore gagné le
dernier championnat d'europe en en
mettant peu en mettant des jeunes en
mettant des jeunes joueurs en plus de
leurs jeunes joueurs qui ont déjà de
1700 et demain ça va être intéressant le
duel entre m vielh radjabov ouais je me
demande je pense qu il s intéressait pas
s'ils en ont parlé tous les deux de
cette ouais ouais
je pense pas qu'ils aient quelconque
animosité entre les deux je pense même
que radjabov doit être plutôt content
pour maxime de la façon dont ça se
décante le ton à des candidats s'effacer
le produit c'est sûr mais il y aura
forcément un petit papa un contentieux
mais une petite envie de prouver quelque
chose quoi peut-être way
peut-être peut-être voilà cette position
j'ai l'impression qu'à retenir est en
train de défendre de manière
intéressante ou quand même qu'ils
fassent garde de ne pas perdre le cuir
arrive c'est un jour 1a défense active
en retour ces sept on n'attaque pas et
c'est encore pire au talent qui fait
qu'un peu trop d'échecs peut-être sur
jacky joui haïti jadida cheikh avait
hilarité dire ils jouent beaucoup aux
échecs aussi en général 1 maintenant je
voulais dire qu'il donnait à 3 d'échecs
avec sa tour pas les mêmes mais ça a
marché dans les deux sens sur quoi c'est
une phrase puis là il a 16 ans donc la
saison est ce qu'on peut vraiment trop
faire de trop faire des chèques d'un
regard intrus qui est marrant c'est tour
7 tu peux le faire sur cavaliers prend
pions prend le pion n'est pas arrêtable
mais bon je pense pas que ça arrive
une touriste tchèque ma vie à mon avis
ils l'envisagent mais problème c'est que
si le renoir bouche s'avance pas grand
chose c'est pour ça qu'il a fait foi
même alentours des deux est obligé
d'aller sur la première somme n'aurait
pas pu préparer c'est un peu mieux
paroisse g2 alentours des 1 et fuit et